pop
[Musique]
prix
ouais
[Applaudissements]
chers amis chers ennemis bienvenue sur
le plateau de tout le monde en parle
l'émission avec nous ce soir
commissionnement
le savoir
la charrière
jean luc lemoine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et de doux
christine deviers jean cau bon sens
mardi
medasys
à cheval et sa majorité
le monde
admet mme guertin
il baisse de 10
[Applaudissements]
je vous demande de vous arrêter laurent
comment ça va bien ça non oui oui c'est
très agréable ça met la patate à lui met
la patate à laurent dis moi ta [ __ ] on
boucle maintenant j'ai fini de tourner
cette séquence
avant ça c'était juste c'était pour le
fasse que j'ai eu beaucoup de mails
disons que ça tu allé très très bien
alors oui ouais c'est quoi beaucoup de
mal pour toi moi je passe une
cinquantaine quoi 50 jerc appel pour
parler du système des lieux des
animations battue c'est bien les
chansons merde
les filles qui voulaient tant portable
en tout c'est bien des filles voulaient
mon portable a donné le thierry tu n'as
pas donné alors je ne passe tu ne veux
pas la permission donne le bombay
s'inscrit en bas de l'écran
magie de la télévision
alors avant de commencer tu ouvres ton
courrier
oui bah oui j'ai pas eu le temps on m'a
donné ça tout à l'heure donc je regarde
un peu l'aquitaine et de qui bah j'avais
des voeux et puis là je les bigoudis et
les maîtres qui il ya eu des voeux de
nicolas sarkozy a dit dans ses biens non
mais ça c'est bien
et de sa femme et de sa femme c'est sûr
qu'il nous présentera public le mec là
citons cette semaine était de 3 ans
avant les présidentielles il est fort
ouais raymond barre sonnait bien
avant de commencer je veux dire un mot
du livre d'olivier ghestin dont on a
parlé la semaine dernière avec sa soeur
emmanuelle béart et lui donc c'est
publié chez gallimard
et effectivement je disais dans
l'émission que olivier gaspard n'étaient
pas financés quand il faisait ses
reportages à l'étranger par l'unicef
bien entendu mille le fait en
partenariat donc avec des agences de
presse et des supports de presse voilà
voilà qui est dit et merci encore à
emmanuel et olivier d'avoir été avec
nous la semaine dernière
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non alors je reçois à l'instant un album
de olivia adriaco je ne savais pas
qu'elle chantait si c'est vrai que j'ai
réclamés à cor et à cri qu'on m'envoie
les albums
oui des artistes et bien sûr adriaco
alors c'est un début encourageant certes
mais je voudrais recevoir des bons
disques m'a battue c'est patent tu là je
n'ai pas écouté
j'aurais qui je voudrais alors à savoir
d'autres ben ali
bientôt sera bientôt parmi nous dans
tout le monde en temps long et de landis
le maire je sais pas la semaine
prochaine je l'écouterai voilà je vais
l'écouter coûte le bien comme ça quand
elle viendra nous a bien passé jamais
regarde l'honneur l'autre qui était
nulle elle est là aussi ce soir là
bon bien alors je reçois maintenant que
xavier anthony et william marshall
[Musique]
tu leur donnes une carte de bons clients
toutes ses fonds propres
le lot qui est soigné son talent ils
sont polis ils ont l'air correct mais
c'est très bien ils sont très beaux
cédant se présente très bien
malheureusement ces gens qui viennent
nous parler beaucoup moins beaucoup
moins gai xavier vous êtes le fils du
chanteur richard anthony effectivement
et ce n'est pas je ne savais pas qu'on
en arriverait là je suis consterné moi
même je donc vous êtes aussi le frère de
alexandre anthony qui a épousé sarah
marshall la petite fille de michel
morgant vous donc william vous êtes le
frère de sarah marshall voilà alors
votre frère alexandre anthony donc à
épouser sa un marshal ils ont eu un
enfant qui s'appelle hall talent et puis
cette semaine à la une de paris match et
une photo de michel morvan et quand on
ouvre le journal on trouve un texte
zoltan l'enfant qui fait pleurer michel
mauran ça c'est terrible je m'en branle
adore donc pourquoi pleures tél elle
pleure parce que son petit fils et
arrière petit fils et notre neveu som
d'or tous les soirs dans un foyer de
l'aide sociale et à la dass il est à la
dass on dit maintenant l'aide sociale et
tous les soirs ce gamin sans dort là il
a 18 mois alors qu'il a une famille
autour de lui composer d'oncles de
tantes nos grands parents arrière grands
parents
moi je suis son parrain et on est tous
là pour qu'il grandisse dans les
meilleures conditions
hélas tous les soirs comme chacun notre
famille et bâle se dit bah voila mon
arrière petit fils est à la dass mais
pourquoi il est à la dass et pas dans la
famille le nom de famille des dans l'une
ou l'autre nous on est on est deux on se
connaît depuis toujours si on est des
familles unies et soudées donc qui
pourrait être dans l'une ou l'autre avec
d'un échange mais le problème c'est que
la justice a laissé le choix à mon frère
et à ma belle soeur soit de confier
leurs enfants à leurs familles soit de
le poser de laisser à l'aide sociale
parce que la justice a considéré qu'il
était inapte à s'occuper de notre neveu
et qu'ils étaient un danger
psychologique pour l'enfant d'accord
donc vous dites que sarah alexandre ont
sorti exprès leurs enfants de la das le
temps de faire des photos pour pour
paris-match taux qui sont parus jeudi
dans paris match
alexandre et sarah qui pleurent dans les
journaux en disant qu'ils n'ont pas de
free qui n'ont pas de souci là ont pris
une limousine pour aller chercher leurs
enfants l'ont sorti de l'aide sociale
l'ont en effet faire une séance photo le
samedi pour pour paris match enfin tout
du moins c'est paris match qui les a
pris serait quelqu'un d'autre selon les
enchères et ils ont ramené très
tranquillement dans leur petite
limousine mon neveu zoltan illés en fait
ils ont la garde de l'enfant le week-end
oui les vacances c'est d'ailleurs ce qui
est étonnant c'est que l' ordonnance de
jugement dit qu'ils sont inaptes comme
je les dis et qu'ils sont un danger pour
pour zoltan mais ils ne le sont plus du
vendredi 18 heures et dimanche 18 heures
l'or noir pendant deux jours ils sont
nathan responsable le résultat et
justice veut pas que nous pendant ce
temps là on sait pas ou une autre ne
veut pas c'est week-end donc whitehorse
qui bouffe s'ils ramassent pas des
conneries pour les mettre à sa bouche on
ne sait pas tout ça on sait pas on se
demande on est dans un flou total
et voilà quand il ya des photos dans
match mais on sait au moins ce qu'il a
fait pendant ce week-end il a fait des
photos votre mère donc
vite zoltan régulièrement l'endroit en
belgique a maintenant elle a eu le droit
à une visite
oui et elle découvre quand elle le voit
qu'en fait il est en pleine régression
ouais c'est à dire que cet enfant ne
s'exprime plus normalement
en fait il est de plus en plus se
replier sur lui-même il s'exprime par
cris voilà il est autiste on peut dire
sans et ben c'est les prémices parce
qu'un baby 18 mois évidemment vous tient
pas un discours et veiller spécialement
mais il a des mots qui sont propres à
lui quand il donne un objet il dit tiens
continent lui on l'apprend dire merci
bonjour papa maman mamie tonton et tous
ces petits mots d'un bébé 18 mois il les
a perdus alors je ne pense pas que c'est
parce que l'aide sociale fait mal son
métier et que c'est parce que les
personnes qui s'occupent de lui ne sont
pas compétentes je pense que c'est parce
que c'est un bébé qui a vu beaucoup de
choses et qu'à 18 mois quand vos parents
vous emmène dans un endroit que vous ne
connaissez pas entouré l'étranger qu'il
vous claque qu'un baiser sur la joue en
10 ans on revient la semaine prochaine
le gamin à 18 ans il le comprend donc il
ne s'alimente plus là perdu du poids et
il régresse
ils ne parlent pas et c'est un gamin qui
a tendance un peu à se mettre dans sa
bulle donc ne veux pas qu'ils restent
dans une bulle en veulent sortir de sa
bulle est le seul moyen pour le sortir
de sa bulle c'est de l'amour mais voilà
aujourd'hui on se dit même l'amour d'une
mère mais il ne l'a même pas en fait
sarah et alexandre sont assez défoncé à
la coca je crois qu'on peut le dire
ouais c'est pas ils le reconnaissent eux
mêmes selon les interviews puisqu il ne
donne jamais la même réponse à la même
question mais ils ne reconnaissent eux
mêmes et c'est un peu un secret de
polichinelle je veux dire pour les gens
qui circulent dans paris et dans les
soirées
c'est pas elle a dit j'ai peur de me
faire tuer par le cartel de cali avec
qui il
c'est à dire alexandre travail donc non
seulement c'est à vous effectivement
prendre de la coke parce que le cartel
de cali et même pas du chocolat au lait
et et puis en plus c'est aussi balancé
sans son mec j'imagine que c'est une
époque où il était en en bisbille pas
spécialement puisque là c'est ce qu'ils
ont enfin on ne sait pas quelle époque
ils sont en bisbille puisqu'il passe
d'un état fort icahn état suicidaire un
état violant b en quelques minutes on
connaît tous les effets de la côte donc
un coup ils sont ils sont excessivement
parano ils sont excessivement
agressif et là ils en sont au stade où
ils brûlent leurs idoles
alors depuis quelques mois c'est vrai
qu'on assiste de la part de donc sarah
et alexandre une espèce de pétage de
plomb un petit peu un couple jet set
qu'on voit partout mais mais à la dérive
en fait soirées people photo festival de
cannes mais mais rien de concret dans
dans les affaires en fait rien de
concret dans le travail
elle essaye d'être mannequin lui laisser
de faire des disques et on peut dire
qu'il se réfugie un petit peu d'une
certaine façon demandant dans cet
imaginaire là non oui je pense qu'ils
ont fini la presse présente un couple
glamour de fils et de filles de familles
réussissant et couple modèle est
apparemment apparemment ayant tous les
moyens 2 et je pense qu'il s'en tienne à
cette image est que quand ils voient les
leurs photos dans les journaux dans les
pages people il sait nous et c'est ce
que nous sommes
mais ce n'est pas la réalité comme
chacun sait la réalité c'est pas ça
c'est de se lever le matin se prendre
par la main et d'aller bosser
soit il est bon fan musiciens mais quand
on a un môme on est bon on n'attend pas
que michael jackson nous appelle on va
bosser ont surtout pas mais surtout
après michael jackson et on va bosser
directement et on se lève le matin pour
les faire n'importe quoi quand on a un
mot une famille pour lui filent à la fin
on va faire n'importe quoi en ce moment
il sort un peu comme bonnie and clyde
ils sont dans paris comme ça ils
traînent ici retraite sont virés des
boîtes sort du match où il ne rentre
plus ils font du scandale il ya des
rapports de police qui parle de
problèmes de grivèlerie de scandales de
d'état d'ébriété sur la voie publique
ils ont été virés déjà de pas mal
d'endroits d'un hôtel raphaël pour pas
le citer votre mère votre mère avait
avait donné un appartement boulevard
flandrin ils sont fait virer aussi du
bouloir flandrin ils sont fait virer par
le syndic humains qui ne gérait plus
d'avoir des voisins qui s'engueulaient
ou ou faisait la fête un soir et
s'envoler le lendemain les allées et
venues à toutes les heures halle où la
flandre as anonyme sa quartier assez
boursiers et les coups de feu et les
coups de feu aux poudres dans un appart
contraint qui commençait à tirer des
coups de feu effectivement et c'est
quand ils ont vu qu'il y avait une arme
que là ils ont dit il ya un bébé dans
cet appartement on peuvent aller c'est
un mec défoncé avec un flingue tiré sur
ce qui bouge
là ils ont décidé de prévenir la brigade
des mineurs qui a retiré la garde dans
un premier temps provisoirement la garde
2e de zoltan à ses parents et qu'il a
confié à la grand mère maternelle ce qui
paraît assez évident je dirais mais ça
aurait pu être la grand mère paternelle
ça aurait pu m la tempe longue julliard
on est tous prêts on a tous les moyens
on a tous le peut-être pas le tout à
fait le temps mais on retrouvera le
temps on a tous fait quoi tout sera
mieux de la d'amour à donner
maintenant je suis pas convaincre j'ai
compris l'association tout sera mieux
que la dass et bien et je vais pas faire
du misérabilisme et mémé de joie qu'il
ya des femmes dans l'assistance ces mecs
des mecs et qu'il ya des cas des mecs et
des pères et des mères de famille qui
qui regardent la télé et je me dis mais
qu'est ce qu'il y a dans la tronche
d'une femme pour aller déposer son
enfant à l'aide sociale mais elle dit
que en fait les familles se déchirent
que ils sont ils sont harcelés non mais
non mais bien ce qu'elle dit oui oui qui
sont harcelés tous les deux par les
familles que les familles se déchirent
que si elle amène à la dass c'est parce
qu a pas d'amour dans la famille et
cetera vous connaissez la version de je
pense que je pense que richard anthony
et mike marshall doit n'avoir pas loin
d'une vingtaine de gosses 2 et
c'est les seuls sarah alexandre sont les
seuls de cette fratrie enfin de cette
faible de ces deux familles réunies ce
sont les seuls à être dans cet état là
je veux dire donc si c'était un problème
familial comme ils le disent on serait
tous barrés or nous on travaille william
travaille moi je serai comme sarah
marshall dit par exemple dans paris
match que finalement michèle morgan le
dit je veux bien donner un appartement à
condition que tu divorces d'alexandre à
l'histoire elle l'a fait à l'envers
parce que nous on connaît l'histoire
sarah est allé voir michel en lui disant
parce que le syndic ayant viré mon frère
et ma belle soeur de cela plus sa part
du genre 80 mètres carrés avec terrasse
1 dans le xvième pas ben oui oui et
quand même m² la terrasse c'est
peut-être à la vente la suite donc quand
ils se sont fait virer c'est comme en
plein sud sud sud ouest voir ci dessus
de résister j'ai compris ben je te donne
mes coordonnées après quand tu visites
je prendrai ma comme l'homme était
commercial boulevard flandrin tabac
juste en dépit de ce que le métro
flandrin flandre à lille à cinq minutes
du bois produit à cinq minutes du bois
qu'elle vous a intéressé dans ce blog à
celle bois de vincennes aussi bon à rien
pas encore mais on sait pas bientôt
ouais je sens force les agents
immobiliers mais ouais parce que quand
ils se sont fait quand le syndicat met
une pression terrible pour les virées de
la parte et que la police était tous les
jours en train de sonner mais on est
obligé de dégager de là partent
évidemment elle est allée voir michel
morvan et à lui a dit je me suis séparé
d'alexandre je suis à la rue elle est
alors qu en fait oui à la rue et à
l'udaf allez michel lui à dix coups de
situer ses parts et d'alexandre je ne
demande qu'à trois jours et le savoir
mais ok je vais t'aider
et dans la minute dans la minute toute
la famille ça va surtout michel a su que
ils n'étaient pas séparés quoique c'est
un bateau qu'ils avaient monté en disant
bon si tu y vas seul avec le gamin qui
dit ouais c'est ça et me sers de ça et
mesdames les grands mères c'est bien ça
n'a pas ému très longtemps parce que
très vite la deuxième version est arrivé
on a su que c'était toujours ensemble
bien alors vous êtes le parrain donc du
jeune zoltan vous avez été témoin
du mariage de votre frère évidemment
vous étiez vous jusqu'au mariage comme
c'est un peu bizarre il y avait déjà pas
michel morvant il fait déjà parler de
charles anthony politiquement courant un
métier pas ou quoi on n'était pas au
courant alors vous vous dites le mariage
a été précipitée en fait parce qu'ils
étaient vendus m6 il était vendu la zone
interdite et ahola le magazine holà donc
il fallait absolument faire ce mariage
le plus rapidement possible c'est pas
les quinze photos la muscu puisque
puisque la chaîne téléphoner en disant
aux rares séquences mariage on va faire
notre émission oui c'est ce qui explique
en fait la précipitation
ça explique un peu la pression de
précipitations ce que ça explique
surtout en fait c'est le fait que le
sujet de l'émission zone interdite c'est
lé mariage impossible et leur mariage
n'était pas impossible quand on s'aime
rien est impossible il suffit d'aller à
merritt publier les bans de se marier
dire fuck off à la femme à la famille
bon c'était pas pas tout à fait ça et le
sujet donc étant lé mariage impossible
ils se sont dits pour faire monter la
sauce
eh bien nous notre mariage est
impossible parce que nos familles se
détestent series ont deux jambes a fait
venir
voilà un sahara des capulet et montaigu
cette soirée alors que 1 on était les
premiers surpris quoi c'était c'était
pour pour pour rentrer dans l'alignement
de la médiatisation toujours la même
histoire
alors vous avez tous avec votre frère
vous vous le voyez je n'ai aucun contact
avec ce jeune homme puisque quand j'ai
essayé de l'appeler il m'a copieusement
insulté parce que j'ai eu le malheur de
lui rappeler qu'ils me devais de
l'argent donc ça s'appelait vous lui
avez offert une voiture où elle a acheté
une voiture pour son mariage pour la
naissance de mon neveu et ensuite quand
il ya des pv à pays les pays bas quand
vous l'appelez en lisant les pays il
vous dis va te faire [ __ ] quoi ouais
parce qu' il n'a jamais daigné met la
voiture à son nom depuis un an et demi
1 ce qui veut dire en dehors du fait bon
j'suis pas une voiture c'est bien sûr sa
vitesse mais je lui demande c'est quoi
comme moi mais j'ai demandé à mon frère
je dis aux coupes la moindre des choses
foule à ton nom oui parce que je savais
que le mec était incapable de se lever
le matin pour descendre mettre des sous
dans le parcmètre et je reçois en ce
moment comme tous les matins je reçois
en moyenne et contre les contraventions
ces quatre par jour boulevard flandrin
donc joueront ce métro flandrin
rappelons le
après dubois se doit de vincennes et je
reçois tous les matins aux moyennes dans
mon courrier quatre contraventions
majoré j'aurais manga depuis un an et
demi
sympa et voitures à affiner la casse
vous avez tous avec votre soeur williams
nouvelle depuis trois ans ah oui depuis
trois ans et encore non une carte une
carte pour les les nouvelles enfin pas
cette année n'en sait que c'est tout et
c'est donc aucun contact mais c'est vrai
ce terminer comment cette affaire nous
ce qu'on voudrait c'est là on est un peu
désabusé dans le sens que on quand on
essaye de sauver des gens et vous le
savez au moins vous thierry c'est que
les gens qui sont dans l'état
d'alexandre et sarah il n'y a qu'eux
mêmes qui peuvent s'en sortir c'est à
dire qu'on peut tout leur dire tout leur
promet de le refaire toutes les menaces
on s'est dit qu'ils avaient besoin
d'amour et de tendresse et d'un bon
démarrage dans la vie donc ils sont
marion alors à donner la patte la
voiture le fric les comptoirs massy pour
les couches privé et on l'a on leur a
vraiment apporté sur un plateau ce que
plein de gens non pas pour commencer
dans la vie qu'ils ont un enfant et
c'est pas non plus la bonne solution les
menaces ne sont pas la bonne solution le
silence n'est pas la bonne solution donc
là on sait qu'il ya qu'eux mêmes qui
peuvent s'en sortir et nous notre but
c'est d'éviter de gâcher l'existence de
ce petit garçon de zoltan ils gâchent
leur existence maintenant c'est leur
problème à savoir qu'ils se démerdent
s'ils veulent se [ __ ] en l'air et
gâcher les opportunités qu'ils ont on
peut plus rien faire
mais s'il vous plaît ne laissez pas ces
gens gâcher la vie d'un petit garçon de
18 mois parce que la cc c'est
dégueulasse et si on ne réagissait pas
ça serait la non-assistance à personne
en danger donc
on aimerait que la justice prenne une
décision claire et michel morvan est
allé voir sarkozy jean-louis mais il
avait quoi sarkozy sarkozy lui a dit qu'
il ne pouvait hélas pas casser un
jugement comme ça quand un juge a rendu
une ordonnance il c'est dur d'être un
enfant de star non c'est pas de plus dur
d'être un enfant de c'est de la foutaise
les gens qui disent je suis j'ai
problème parce que je suis un enfant de
star ou quand je dois t'arrêter qu'elle
rapporte est le fils de richard anthony
aussi possible tiens justement
plus facile pour moi et pour aller
entendre toujours s'il peut être un ton
père je ne sais pas moi mais ça
s'appelle des acouphènes telle il ya
plusieurs prévenir
justement c'était ma dernière question
il va comment richard anthony il y a des
acouphènes
il a des acouphènes il va bien il est
lui même il est un peu effondré de ce
qui se passe 1 qu'est ce que c'est son
petit-fils et que et qu'il effondré de
voir cesser cette situation et qu'il
voudrait que ce petit garçon soit élevé
au sein d'une famille unie ce que l'on
est passé
les seules personnes qui sont en conflit
avec cette famille sont alexandre et
sarah et ils ne sont pas en conflit avec
leur famille ils sont en conflit avec la
société matière merci à mr si je me le
dire simplement que alexandre et sarah
peuvent venir témoigner sur ce plateau
s'ils le souhaitent
la semaine prochaine c'est l'émission où
tout le monde parle merci beaucoup
[Musique]
et maintenant
m
merci patrick sébastien
[Musique]
salut la fellation
bonne année dix mois alors que suppose
cette affaire toile je suis vachement
content je vais te dire j'ai entendu
parler d'amour ça m'a fait depuis le
temps ça fait des années que je parle de
ça à chaque fois je passe pour un vieux
con t'as dalle côté la camsa d'un côté
l'amour je crois qu'il faut pas en
vouloir aux gamins ils sont dans la came
un qui est une tu le sais utiliser de la
fille ont fumé un pétard à côté de toi
ça te mets en colère je suis j'aime pas
ça j'ai dans ma vie privée j'ai eu une
une ex épouse qui est tombé là-dedans
j'ai réussi à la sortir de là à la faire
désintoxiquer aujourd'hui elle a un
enfant
elle est très heureuse elle me remercie
mme à l'époque où elle était dedans elle
était abominable a été ignorée bien de
tomber dans la teinture toi
t'as pas envie de trop sortir un jeu ou
pas direct à partir et je retourne chez
toi je te promets valoir c'est la guerre
alors non je voulais dire que quand
elles étaient dans cette situation là
était abominable était exécrable
moi je suis quelqu'un qui pratique le
pardon et je crois que les moments
question c'est pas à eux
enfin c'est pas eux les responsables
c'est les mecs qui leur fils de la cams
et les juges qui ont décidé que ça
allait à la dass plutôt que d'aller dans
la famille mais les mots il faudrait
pouvoir les choper les désintoxiquer
voilà écoute on va continuer à passer
pour les vieux cons mais je continue à
penser qu'à ça je pense que c'est la
meilleure chose
le pardon l'amour en tendant alors
patrick vous êtes l'homme du record
historique d'audience à la télévision
avec le grand bluff sur tf1 en 1992 17,5
millions de téléspectateurs qui depuis
plus rien dans tous les cas depuis plus
personne n'a fait autant c'est clair
ouah je pense que ça c'est elle et
c'était les circonstances mais rappelle
toi avant le quai ses méthodes de m6
étaient en grève et la nuit des héros en
face ouais grave vous animez produisait
actuellement une fois par mois le plus
grand cabaret du monde donc le samedi en
prime time sur toi sur france 2 voilà
d'ailleurs quand j'étais là-bas quand
elle insisté et puis la chanson à la fin
pour arrêter
je sais que c'est chiant mais moi j'en
viens scheer
[Applaudissements]
je souhaite un prompt rétablissement à
seb
oui je sais toi père et il en a pour
trois mois de plâtre
on pense à lui et imagine aussi message
alors le plus grand cabaret du monde
donc effectivement quand vous êtes là
c'est mieux pour nous parce que vous
voulez c'est quand même
france 2 avec un peu plus de monde
devant le poste c'est clair parce que je
sais pas ce que je préfère c'est la
chanson de l'afrique et bien avoir été
ça non mais ça m'éclate en messie
et à
si j'ai des amis qui pour m'emmerder de
mettre le petit bonhomme en mousse et
attends tu vas voir parce que là je suis
un peu d'en faire une fille s'appelle
les papillons c'est pire parce que je me
suis dit qu'en étant sortir de tout ça
et avoir un métier honnête des cheveux
gonflés et je vais en faire une qui
gonfle mais je dis dans la chanson
qu'elle gonfle encore plus mais parce
que j'adore ça c'était comme mon ami
rappel mais sera une des chansons de
merde et adore c'est un ordinateur est
ce que c'est vraiment des chansons
d'amour c'est oui ou non votre coeur
[Musique]
c'est
rada punition lors patrick votre boîte
de prod magic c'est une petite structure
efficace et est rentable alors les
grosses sociétés comme endemol et
rachète tout le paf auront essayé de
vous racheter des beaucoup d'argent des
milliards de centimes
et pourquoi vous avez dit non parce que
je veux être libre ah ouais parce que je
suis un artiste avant tout à moins
d'être animateur fin je considère qu'un
jouet léonard de vinci je me considère
pas comme un artiste tu vois non mais
chez moi quand et où dans mon bureau via
le bus de ces drogues comme les autres
dans mon bureau dans mon bureau il ya le
buste de 1,6 je suis pareil à de vinci
ayant déboursé courageux parce que la
plupart des boîtes de prod à paris ont
été vendus à endemol qui aujourd'hui se
disent encore à magic man touba sais pas
comment on aime le blé ouais moi
j'existe à l'envié j'ai grandi sans
argent 1
j'aime ça comme tout le monde vraiment
j'étais sur tf1 il y en avait beaucoup
et puis à un moment il y en a eu trop un
art c'est bizarre de dire que tu es un
trop d'argent ayant donc ça rend dingue
dans un magasin on regarde plus les
étiquettes et moi c'est pas moi c'est
pas je sais pas vivre comme ça donc je
préfère être libre c'est à dire être
dans ma petite structure faire les
émissions que j'ai envie de faire mon
nom j'ai envie de le faire regarder l
éthique et à voir mais regardez lés
étiquettes et à voir mes potes avec moi
et surtout à mes potes avec moi ça fait
25 ans et vous bossez en bonne voie
c'est un problème parce qu'aujourd'hui
pouvez pas vous arrêter
il y avait un genre pas les mettre à la
rue marie ya 20 ans pouviez vous arrêtez
je ne voudrais pas parce que je continue
aussi pour ça c'est vrai que moi je me
pose des questions depuis très longtemps
j'ai envie d'aller faire l'artiste pour
200 personnes parce que c'est un vrai
plaisir toute façon c'est d'être sur
scène là je repars d'habitude je faisais
des galas que l'hiver maintenant je veux
que l'été maintenant j'ai en fait divers
je suis à je suis à rouen et à lille je
sais février là c'est alors avec le
petit bonhomme mais avec plein d'autres
choses
non il ya ça
mais lille et rouen ils peuvent toucher
du blé pour catastrophes naturelles ah
oui plan est bien pour les villes alors
plan orsec est jeune on je fais je fais
des imitations dans jeudi puis je dis
tout ce que je peux pas dire à la télé
voilà donc alors maintenant on passe aux
choses moi moins gai moins heureuse
à la fin de l'année vous est proposé sur
france 2 3 émission qui s'appelle de
l'autre côté du miroir
basée sur deux ingrédients qui ont fait
votre succès le déguisement et
l'imitation vous étiez donc dans la peau
de vingt-quatre personnalités vivantes
ou disparus qui rencontraient leurs
homologues ou leurs proches c'est tout
ce que tu aimes bien de mes critiques
excellentes en plus tout le monde a dit
ça y est c'est la première fois que j'ai
eu des critiques dans télérama dans libé
dans tout ça c'est ce que je voulais en
fait à lui que d'habitude ouais oui
c'était on est on est on est loin de ce
que vous faites habituellement c'est
parce que non c'est une démarche
d'artiste plus vrai si j'avais envie de
faire partie de l'aventuré a été
formidable a travaillé pendant on a
tourné pendant un mois d'abord on a créé
24 chansons
oui messieurs c'est à vous avez écrit et
composé 24 chansons à la dernière de
salir info ferrer info lama donc là où
c'était bien il faut il que les bonnes
âmes on peut être multiple toit entre le
personnage que tu es là est celui que je
croise bois de boulogne la nuit à
l'arrêt
les eaux
tu viens de détruire la réputation
les gens vont le croire on a été
vachement gentil en évitant me dire ce
la preuve c'est que tu y vas toujours
chaud et déjà des cartes de japonais qui
s'appelle copie conforme et ses 24
chansons à la manière de vaincre bien
l'amour
[Musique]
le seigneur
château
j'avais jamais un froid j'avais jamais
trop
je tuais mékrokro
m
pas
oui
là
[Musique]
bright star
me malka
l'onat et le teint
vers 10 may
au minimum 15
un cola
offrir à boire quand tu veux arrêter
pour tout le monde
un blaireau qui doit vivre avec ton tu
veux
m
train d'y aller bien
le père lui dix de retrouvés
qu'est ce que tu veux
et ce pacte et des filles respecter les
vieux ne pas croire ce qui brille si ce
n'est quelques 6e et ne jamais aïe
le plus puissant que toi et ne pas trop
prendre 10 lorsque tu ne sais pas voilà
patrick sébastien copie conforme
24 chansons à la manière de
on y trouvera les photos on sait que les
vrais fabien ben c'est vrai mais attend
il ya un truc là sur la poste sur la
pochette du dvd là c'est moins déguisée
par contre avec la tête des gens c'est
pas mal non plus justement pour ceux qui
n'ont pas vu les trois émissions de
l'autre côté du miroir elle existe en
dvd et vhs et vu le nombre de gens qui
l'ont vu
vous allez en vendre beaucoup il est pas
encore sorti sortir à l'air 25 février
un jour ici parisien vous approchez
votre manque d'humilité toutes les
critiques je les comprends salir les
gens qui m'ont dit on s'est un peu
ennuyé où les gens qui me disent on
n'aime pas je comprends ça mais le
manque d'humilité d'orge et papy j'ai vu
que c'était pas moi qui étais les
personnages que jouer cette mobilité à
mitterrand je comprends et et vous
l'avez traité de gros cons oui il y en a
un autre que vous avez traité de gros
cons sans l'ombre d'un talent c'est
bruno gallois patron des guignols qui
étaient là aurait dû faire un bisou
d'ailleurs parce qu'en fait parler au
téléphone juste après ton émission je
peux raconter ce qui s'est passé que
c'est bien sûr parce que il a même
failli venir avec moi ce soir je mets
sérieusement milla breaks d'affilée non
mais avec avec moi il en a plus j'ai
plus de plus de problème avec lui n'ont
en fait ce qui s'est passé il m'a traité
d'enculé chez toi l'autre jour
d'ailleurs
avant j'étais un peu mais c'est vrai
c'est marrant parce que au début me
traiter de corps pré-retraités [ __ ]
saveurs et les deux sont peut-être pas
incompatibles oui d'ailleurs j'en
connais et non en fait ce qui s'est
passé c'est que pendant des années les
guignols vont taper dessus et puis un
jour je sais tellement énervé il ya un
journaliste qui est venue m'interviewer
j'ai dit c'est facile d'être méchant
gratuitement comme ça j'ai dit tu veux
te soit méchant gratuitement je
comprends que gaccio soit méchant vie la
tête de sa gonzesse ce qui est d'une
méchanceté c'est pas bien ce que j'ai
dit et j'ai dit ça le mec l'a écrit et
moi je me suis dit après vraiment c'est
pas bien parce que michèle bernier en
l'occurrence t elle franchement j'ai
trouvé ça très inélégant de ma part donc
j'ai écrit une lettre à michel emmené en
m'excusant et d'ailleurs si elle est
devant la télé je voulais encore une
fois lui dire que moi je suis un gros
con parce que j'aurais jamais jean
michel non mais attends c'est vrai en
plus j'ai vu son truc c'est fantastique
je voudrais m'excuser vraiment
profondément et le gros con dans en
l'occurrence c'est moi c'est bien mais
non franchement parce que vraiment c'est
j'aimerais bien qu'il reconnaisse leur
comme non mais c'est pas lui c'est pas
bien ce que j'ai dit mais j'ai voulu
j'ai voulu être crétin vous vous est
dédié à gaccio quand j ai gassion j'ai
appelé la l'autre jour je lui ai dit
écoute fuchs explique jean une lettre à
michel je m'excuse encore etc et il a
très bien compris je suis c'est des fois
toi aussi tu fais du malade et à des
gens j quand vous nous charger nous ne
réagit n'est pas le mal que ça fait à
nos gamins et c'est finalement tout ça
c'est une question de de ce que je
disais au début de pardon ce jeune homme
a traité dans le cul les jeux les
regrets au téléphone je me suis excusé
moi
il s'est excusé aussi je crois qu'ils
les gens dans la rue faisait un petit
peu plus sa non pour des choses qui
finalement d'envoi n'en valent pas la
peine
ça y est quand même vachement mieux
non
est-ce que tu as quelque chose à dire à
bruno gaccio non mais je suis je trouve
ça mignon quoi je trouve que les les
inimitiés tout ça moi j'étais très très
marquée par senna et prost il se
déchiraient par journaux interposés
s'insulter un jour j'ai vu prost porté
le cercueil de sienna et j'ai trouvé que
c'était une image assez forte sur les
sur les antennes qui sont semences moi
aussi je trouve de l'amour maintenant on
va dire du bien ça va changer un petit
peu et ce qu'on peut dire un peu bien de
jacques chirac
ouais ouais vous parler au téléphone
quand même on sait pas eu depuis un
moment quand même avant il a eu son
épouse à sa fille un qui vient mon
anniversaire non je trouve ce sens je
changerai jamais à l'époque je me
faisais jeter la pierre par tout le
monde parce que j'étais le seul artiste
qui avait le courage de dire vraiment ce
qu'ils pensaient alors ce n'est pas dans
le sens de penser que chirac était un
humaniste ce que je pense au même titre
que mitterrand qui était aussi un
humaniste
après les compétences politiques des uns
et des autres c'est que je fais pas de
politique je fais pas vraiment de
politique j'ai pas de carte bien non
mais je suis inquiet surtout parce que
chirac et mitterrand pour moi sont de
grands hommes d'état avec tout ce que
cela comprend tout ça comment de
compromission en plus et d'humanisme je
regarde derrière je vois pas grand chose
justement si on disait du bien de
sarkozy il bosse j'ai reçu une carte de
voeux en tout cas
ibos il bosse maintenant je pense que
c'est un bon surveillant général
ouais c'est pas forcément un bon serveur
général qui ferment proviseur tu crois
ce sais pas je sais franchement c'est
mais au moins au moins jusqu'à ce que à
quoi s'est tu crois qu'il est président
la république
honnêtement je ça maroc j'aimerais pas
trop ah ouais ouais je crois qu'il est
bien comme une île intérieure
il veut je sais qu'il veut pas mais ça
serait pas mal comme ça et puis en
freinant un peu quand même quelques
excès parce que les flics qui se
prennent pour des cow boys ouais ça
c'est vrai bien le pen ans on disait du
bien de le pen à je voulais c
non plus je suis quand même content de
voir que tout ce qu'on m'a reproché à
l'époque dose on devient la démarche que
j'avais eu à savoir de de dire je vais
critiquer ce mec parce que je partage
pas du tout ses idées mais je vais quand
même lui donner le droit de réponse à
l'époque en avons tous deux mondes
m'était tombé dessus aujourd'hui la mode
est plutôt de dire laissons le parler
ouais ne diabolisons pas ouais et c'est
ce que si ce n'était des dirigeants ces
arguments plutôt que pas lui répondre et
ben moi je pense qu'il faut lui parler
d'amour encore une fois
enfin je vais pas on a du mal à dire du
bien alors brigitte bardot à j'aime
beaucoup mais sans compter non on va
tenter un peu raide j'oublie non non non
oui le bouquin le machin etc
je vous dis pas c'est un livre qu'elle a
écrit je sais mais c'est un mythe un
pensé à la femme arrête avec les niches
ont essayé d'être concentré sur le nom
je sais pas moi je gg j'ai une tendresse
pour cette femme j'y peux rien
je n'arrive pas à les tester quoi ah non
surtout pas de long tu sais c'est
marrant que tu me dis ça parce que j'ai
passé
ça va vous paraître bizarre wever vieux
con j'ai passé un après-midi à trois
semaines entre les deux avec de longs et
bardos et les deux tu m'as fait peur
non mais franchement c'est officiel il
ya que toi casse-cou rasées pour le noël
des animaux non ah bah oui il a tout de
suite fait pour noël les animaux j'étais
avec la manade et le blaireau bah voilà
remplis à plus tu fais le malin c'est de
l'humour c'est vrai je vais te dire j'ai
comme j'ai pas quitter mon enfance moi
de me retrouver assis entre deux longs
et bardot ouais j'ai plein de souvenirs
qui me semble être pour moi eh ben je me
suis pas fait autrement je
l'émerveillement dans le gamin a lors du
noël des animaux mais souvent j'ai
remarqué que ces gens-là et préférez les
animaux aux êtres humains je pense pas
j'arrive pas je n'arrive pas quelle que
soit la personne à détester
complémentaires j'ai l'âge est un mec
quand tu vas avoir du mal à dire du bien
qui dieu donné à ben vous et combien
d'années pendants moi je m'en souviens
pas mais à une époque où il y encore il
ya deux semaines bonne année bonne santé
tu voulais pas ici avec dieudonné devait
donner cet été là j'étais choqué parce
qu'elle n'aimait pas les noirs à
l'époque alors justement à l'époque de
son ouais ça a été le plus virulent
il a même dit qu'il fallait me fillion
au lance flammes a été très riche a dit
la même chose et puis avec les problèmes
qu'il a eus là chez fogiel
j'ai appelé dieudonné j'ai pris mon
téléphone j'ai compati à skis à ce
qu'ils vivaient en lui disant tu vois
c'est ce que j'ai vécu moi un degré
moindre parce que moi je les ai vécus 1°
- tu faisais partie de la meute et
aujourd'hui tu as là me tâter trouve toi
et tu vois ce que ça fait donc je
voulais que tu saches que sans porter de
jugement sur ce que thalys est d'accord
ou pas d'accord je serai toujours
solidaire des gens qui ont la meute
lâchée à leurs trousses
et même si tu n'arrives et du mal eh ben
il m'a dit que ça lui faisait du bien de
sentir que quelqu'un sur lequel il avait
craché viennent vers lui en lui disant
solidaire et moins c'est ma philosophie
c'est une chance de la partager et que
ce soit gaccio dieudonné je trouve que
quelque part même avec leurs erreurs
c'est sain que des mecs puissent quand
même ouvrir leur gueule dans un pays on
a plus de succès quand on la ferme
ou quand on l ouvre en chantant en
groupe
non
mais tant de richesses à donner
[Musique]
hélas
jamais
vous avez assez à la manière de serge là
celle-là je vais pas chanter alors celle
là je vais pas chanter sur scène en
milieu dé au milieu des bêtises des
saltimbanques vous en êtes un patrick
sébastien de salt un bon jour on dit
sinon vous soyez chez endemol vous nous
l'avez dit alors bien parce que t'as pas
signé chez endemol des animaux en alors
à 17 ans donc vous êtes à brides avec
marié marié avec un enfant et un
appartement avec un enfant mais c'est
vrai qu'en france et de l'aménager
français si vous êtes pions pour pour
payer dressage en fac de lettres voilà
et là vous vous réalisez que finalement
votre avenir est tout tracé
les pantoufles à côté de la télé les
week-ends aller voter prof de lettres si
possible voilà et là vous vous barrez je
pète les plombs
ouais je me dis que moi je suis pareil
hein je me dis si l'on à 18 ans j'ai
quitté ma province à l'oreille je me dis
que si je pars pas maintenant je veux
pas me retourner à 40 en dix ans
j'aurais pu partir je vais pas essayer
c'est comme aujourd'hui à 50 ans il ya
des choses que je veux faire il ya un
personnage que je veux changer
il ya du théâtre que j'ai des choses que
je veux dire et je me dis je veux pas me
retrouver à 70 piges en me disant tu
pouvais les français ne les a pas faits
pour vous retrouvez donc sur le quai de
la gare d'austerlitz en septembre 74 et
là c'est un peu la galère vous harceler
les cabarets de la capitale pcc les
meilleurs moments et voilà vous dites
j'ai jamais été aussi heureux qu'à ce
moment-là libri j'étais plus heureux
qu'aujourd'hui
ouais libre pas de responsable partie
facile à utiliser l'art hiscox à la main
en appelant les cabarets en disant je
m'appelle patrick sébastien vous ne
connaissez pas du formidable j'étais
libre et puis j'avais pas les
responsabilités
j'avais tout devant moi je pouvais m'en
aller je pourrais me casser je peux
marquer quand je aujourd'hui il ya des
gens qui travaillent avec moi et ça j'ai
des responsabilités j'ai des enfants tom
tas de trucs je peux pas
sinon il ya longtemps que j'ai pris une
valise serait parti maintenant à
l'époque vous dites vous étiez heureux
mais comme on faisait des auditions par
exemple limité pour vider les mecs vous
dise
en bas on voit bien de façon le paysan
t'as pas de mal à le faire il espère que
sa composition sur donc amis ou l'inde
mais qui m'a fait monter sur la table il
m'a dit ça doit pas être un rôle de
composition en casse toi chez toi moi je
sortais du rugby je me disais je vais
lui mettre un grand marron dans la
gueule à ce moment là dans cinq ans
après vous fait l'olympia et et quand
vous devenez célèbre quand vous faites
l'olympia vous espériez qu'à ce moment
là
votre père vous devenant célèbre se
manifeste pour vous reconnaît ben non
c'est mon héros de fiction préférée
enfin vous pensé quand même qu étant
célèbre île viendrai vous voir quand
même non pas forcément
je pense même le contraire je pense que
même n'ayant pas eu le courage de le
faire car je n'étais pas connu
c'est un monsieur qui a quand même de
l'honneur et qu'il ne ferait a priori
pas plus pas moins été connue alors vous
dites j'ai tellement souffert petits de
ne pas choisir ma vie que je veux au
moins choisir ma mort je dis simplement
que comme on choisit pas sa vie quand on
est j'aimerais bien choisir ma mort ça
va énerver ma femme en coulisse appelle
ici
elle supporte pas qu'on parle de ça je
suis très suicidaire mais mais mais je
suis pas suicidaire
je vais me flinguer parce que ça marche
pas moi j'aimerais tant leur rêve absolu
c'est d'arriver à déterminer moment de
ta vie ou telle mieux qu'en top
et ouais et partir là ouais ouais c'est
à dire les lamas l'accusé envers demande
après quoi c'est peut-être cette offre
maintenant c'est peut-être maintenant je
sais pas j'ai pas eu les couilles de
massane réfléchir les avoir j'aimerais
avoir les couilles de le faire c'est
parce que vous êtes suicidaire que vous
n'avez pas beaucoup chez avant 6h30 du
matin
non c'est parce que je suis désespéré et
que si je reste lucide tard comme
beaucoup de gens j'ai tendance à trop
gamberger donc j'attends d'être épuisé
pour éteindre la lumière à 7h du matin
et 6 heures
[Musique]
alors copie conforme 24 chansons à la
manière des plus grands je vais vous
poser des questions à la manière des
plus grands c'est l'interview à la
manière de
[Musique]
alors on va commencer avec nikos aliagas
questions de nikos aliagas à laquelle
j'allais répondre batterie patrick
sabatier bonser alors vous faites votre
grand retour tout à fait oui bien sûr
j'espère bientôt chanter à star académie
michel drucker patrick vous qui la
connaissez bien pour nous dire à
bernadette qu'elle peut revenir quand
elle veut le dimanche après midi
magnifique ppda ça vous gêne pas tous
ses cheveux dans votre travail ne soit
sauvé dieu mireille dumas est ce que le
fait que vous ayez choisi limitation
n'est pas imputable à l'attitude de
votre père qui vous a obligé à exister à
travers d'autres personnes patrick et
vous mireille est ce que vous faites ça
par rapport à l'attitude que vous
infligez votre père alexandre je vous
regardez moi dans les yeux
alors envoyé à besançon pernaut vous
écrit des paroles et musique c'est pour
échapper à la criminelle pression
fiscale qui règne en france c'est un peu
marqué florent pagny à benjamin castaldi
taqwa comme mobileme charles villeneuve
quand vous chantez pipeau le yach vous
dénoncez les pitbulls des terroristes
islamiques à la manière de gérard holtz
ça te dirait patrick de faire une
traversée du désert avec moi je voyage
pas moi tu sais bien je bouge je bouge
pas moi je reste en france il ya crû à
noter d'accord et ce qui m'intéressait
et le bois
et maintenant
à
est lâché
ce persia
voici la tâche à saint pierre
[Musique]
elle est top milian moi je resterai des
as c'est gentil seraient des heures des
heures à vous regarder
abbas est très gentil je bosse bisous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
gachassin pierre vous êtes la première
pousse bisou de la soirée il ya de la
tendresse dans cette émission évidemment
il ya patrick sébastien et de l'amour
damman beaucoup d'amour alors je suis
très heureux de vous revoir parce que
d'abord vous êtes canadienne mais pas
québécoise vous avez pas d'accent un peu
quand même
ah oui pas l'accent québécois c'est un
mélange de plein axe en fait des bandes
est quand même sorti des cornes en
suisse est très jolie c'est gentil
et troisièmement j'ai appris en novembre
en lisant la revue canadienne sept jours
mais je me camoufle assez bien c'est
bien foutu suis fier de ce que j'ai fait
avec la pomme dalder c les pompes du 46
et pas peur donc j'ai appris en lisant
la revue canadienne sept jours que
c'était fini avec votre animateur de
radio là sébastien benoit bah vous avez
surtout appris que les journalistes
québécois souvent ne vérifient pas leurs
sources
merde bien que les québécois chez vous
chez nous ils nous appellent
chez nous ils vous appellent avant le
chrono
dans la peau tels que vous avez cassé
vous avez remis le couvert ce qui arrive
très souvent dans un couple non non non
non non ça continue avec ce mec
ouais mais emilie là bas il ya là bas
c'est sûr oui oui c'est certain le temps
devant rappeur donc on va attraper mais
là aussi si vous m'attraper que l'accent
canadien ça vous laisse indifférent à la
partie
alors
amr rganisée yan wei qui bouchent les
oreilles des besoins alors bien patrick
je ne sais pas c'est que la première
fois que natasha est venu dans cette
émission vous en souvenez de ça à un
moment je lui dis qu'elle est pour vous
l'homme idéal puisque on lui chercher un
mari à l'époque et elle m'a répondu et
un catholique croyant avec une grosse
[ __ ]
moi j'ai cru que c'était mon portrait
robot que faisais tu n'es pas si croyant
aspects de croyants voilà donc
effectivement c'est pour ça qu'on
s'intéresse aussi tu comprends ma vie à
la jeune fille sa vie à ses origines
famille des idées amis quoi des idées le
samedi est un poisson de la famille des
élus
merci ça tombe à sa culture la baffe il
est super fort en zoophilie et c'est un
poisson d'eau douce ou d'eau salée d'eau
de mer c'est un migrateur et on
l'appelle saint-pierre parce que la
légende veut que saint pierre les prix
pour les facs rachid pièces d'or et donc
les deux dates les deux côtés sur saint
pierre
le service public met la musique
et
je suis du service mu ouest gamin qui
parle de 8 et l'autre de saint-pierre
normalement l'animateur devrait être là
non c'est pour ça que l'on est là pour
apporter une dimension culturelle à
l'émission alors se lancer sur mon
contrat voilà la famille des idées dans
la vie culturelle
alors en plus maintenant vous êtes riche
non en fait ça dépend ce qu'on entend
par et riche l'album précédent ce qui a
même vendu à 600 mille exemplaires merci
obispo d'ailleurs au passage mais c'est
pas mal d'argent non quand même non non
mais un jour tu pourras tu acheté des
manches quand même sa vente ait de
l'argent quand même 600 mille albums 700
mille sept cent mille c'est quoi ça
n'arrête pas 800 1000 mhz du temps les
gens achètent sein par milliers vous
faites quoi ils sont votre argent bas
pour l'instant rien d'assez spécial je
voyage un peu
je vais avouer que je travaille beaucoup
donc je fais rien d'autre parce que
c'est ce que j'ai envie de faire quoi
ouais vous payez pas des gigolos
catholique croyant pour l'instant non
mais j'y songe non alors donc pour votre
nouvel album vous avez repris obispo
évidemment on ne change pas une équipe
qui gagne et même une reprise de l'uci
sur votre album s'appelle l'instant
d'après ça parle d'amour 7 fera plaisir
patrick ça parle d'amour et le single en
promo s'appelle tant que c'est toi
[Musique]
randonnée je sens ici
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà la tâche à saint pierre
[Applaudissements]
s'appelle l'instant d'après
et alors il ya une autre chanson qu'on
va entendre beaucoup les prochaines
semaines ça s'appelle quand on cherche
l'amour
vous
alors en 2003 faisait était consacré
révélation de l'année aux victoires de
la musique en 2004 il se rend compte de
leur erreur
je me retire le prix en 2004 il ya les
nrj music awards si vous êtes nominé
artiste féminine francophone de l'année
sans manche il en rajoute club c'est la
catégorie s'en prend maintenant ils sont
réjouis
et si j'osais l'avoir moi je ne
parierais pas là dessus parce qu'il ya
bahia hélène ségara il ya jennifer et y
en a d'autres mais c'est justement non
c'est vous ben voyons
bah ça me ferait très plaisir si je n'ai
non non je déconne que là bas on le sait
n'ont pas cependant n'était pas dans ma
catégorie tourner dans le showbiz mon à
voter pour toi si gentil bah oui annoncé
depuis lustres mieux les chanteuses sans
manche on s'en est parlé avant et c'est
toi pour nous c'est toi creusement
chauffe ouais alors quand vous aurez
votre nrj music awards
natacha faisait faire plein d'interviews
à la con comme toujours il ya plein de
gens qui vont bien vous posez des
questions stupides on va voir on va vous
entraîner
on va faire l'interview des bibles
[Musique]
attention petit training tâches à faire
ce que tu fais c'est ta passion non pas
du tout natacha tu manges après ou avant
le concert à 20 est ce que tu te définir
et natacha comme une rebelle sans manche
toujours on est toujours dans la je suis
je crois une faune se rebelle en six ans
que oui j'ai des opinions bien arrêtées
malheureusement
jean facilement influençable donc je
fais je fais rapidement des compromis
est-ce que tu as froid natacha j'ai dit
non j'ai pas froid mais j'avoue que j'ai
souvent la charte de poids non sky
carrément ya un air frais et avec vos
talents de voiliers la chair de la poule
la chair de poule
[Musique]
natacha aurait dans la galinette là on
est dans la foule avec tout ce succès
n'a jamais eu peur de plus appartenir
est-ce qu'on s'appartient penses tu
avoir été davantage influencés par les
stones ou les beatles seront vraiment
c'est une question qui nous vient des
émissions si les vraies questions ça je
sais maintenant avec quels chanteurs ou
chanteuses aimerais tu faire un duo à
part évidemment obispo avec garou j'en
ai souvent fait dans des télés dans des
concerts mais sur album jamais et
j'aimerais bien d'accord très bien la
réponse est bien est ce que tu pourrais
dire un mot pour tous les
téléspectateurs de tout le monde en
parle
regardant ta caméra restez à l écoute
quoi
[Musique]
emma pranger accueil
jean luc lemoine
[Musique]
bonsoir ça va mais ça va donner c'est
tellement jean-luc natasha st bien oui
natacha ghz et j'ai vu ses clips
patrick déjà croisé dans une de ses
émissions et laurent j'ai déjà croisé en
dehors et jean marie bigard exact 0,5 à
bien alors on vous connaît jean luc
lemoine à travers l'émission de laurent
ruquier notamment on a tout essayé mais
on sait aussi que parallèlement vous
mener une carrière sur scène d'abord
avec mon colocataire est une merde et
ensuite avec jean luc lemoine est
inquiétant qui sort en dvd spectacle que
vous allez faire au bataclan donc du 27
au 31 c'est ça mais là ça sera les cinq
dernières à paris après on le verra plus
à paris ce spectacle ah bon ouais c'est
fini après on peut acheter le dvd
oui ou non voir en tournée mais faut se
déplacer un faut y aller ouais donc le
27 au bataclan
oui du 27 au 31 n'hésitez pas alors moi
j'ai vu votre votre spectacle
j'ai trouvé ça très fort donc je vais
essayer de ne pas me faire piquer le dvd
keller mais ce que j'aimerais bien le
j'aimerais bien revoir
est-ce qu'il est à l'intérieur parce que
souvent hélas ouf
mais il ya que toi qui a reçu le dvd
doit classer la boulette tarsul liste
d'olivier adriaco c'est vrai alors il ya
un truc terrible dans votre spectacle
c'est qu'au début vous vous jouer
vraiment comme une patate s'asseoir on
se dit [ __ ] s'il faut passer deux
heures avec ce mec tu me suis dit qu'est
ce que j'ai fait via les et puis on
découvre après que c'est heureusement un
jeu
ça soulage à jouer vous jouez mal ah
ouais non non je fais pas semblant
j'aime bien le malaise au début quand
les gens savent pas où ils sont tombés
ces eaux là là quelle horreur finalement
une bonne surprise après enfin j'espère
ce qui est drôle aussi c'est qu'à la fin
vous restez sur scène et vous attendez
que les gens sortent et comme ils
sortent pas tant vous êtes là évidemment
pas obligé de sortir un par un voilà
c'est ça c'est assez rigolo alors valoir
entre les deux entre ceux des bus et
cette fin il ya effectivement un humour
formidable et un humour noir qui fait
rire jaune marchand de couleurs
marchande
je fais des questions sont pourquoi le
surveillant de la maternelle est si
cruel avec les enfants là parce qu'un
enfant dépressif et un enfant calme
pourquoi votre client agence
matrimoniale ne veut pas spécialement
d'une femme intelligente ccc pas seul et
il a rien contre l'intelligence mais à
choisir je vais faire une femme je
comprends pourquoi pourquoi votre gars
du nord veut absolument adopter un
enfant parce que son chien est mort il a
de l'amour à donner mais voilà c'est ça
il a pas d'amour à donner
voilà alors on comprend pourquoi vous
entendez bien avec laurent ruquier parce
que vous avez la même dévotion pour
pierre doris qui était le roi de le roi
de l'humour noir
c'est vraiment inquiétant en fait est-ce
que vous avez déjà par exemple arracher
les ailes d'une mouche
non quand même pas nouvelles bases d'un
poussin oui mais d'une louche non
est ce que vous aimez grincer des dents
non mais par contre j'aime bien quand ça
grince dans la salle 1
la gc c'est vrai que de temps en temps
il ya un petit malaise justement sur sur
des trucs on a dit tout à l'heure ça
j'aime bien quand les gens sont à la
limite de l'ue et ouais
est-ce que vous traînez le soir près des
écoles le soir non il ya plus personne
mais vers 17 heures oui est-ce que vous
marchiez des boulettes de papier alu oui
oui j'adore c'est à dire jamais compris
pourquoi mythe et du chocolat dans les
tablettes de papier alu nous un petit
sourire étrange quand je dis le mot
vagin vagin enfin annoncer ses pas
surgissent un peu de bave mais pas de
sourire las
vous votez front national j'aime la
déconne il ya des limitations
[Musique]
ça va bien aujourd'hui vous allez faire
un peu de sport vous allez vous la donne
et non jour en skate bah voilà ok j'aime
pas rancunier
j'admire les jeunes
j'aime le dialogue je suis pompier c'est
mon métier
oui on s'entraîne dur mais ça vaut le
coup d'être pompier ça veut dire sauver
des vies humaines
éteindre des feux conduire des camions
rouges avec des grosses sirène raté
tenue en cuir gratos
les casques qui brillent comme des
petites cuillers brillante monté au
dernier étage de la caserne et
redescendre en se frottant sexe contre
une grande barbe et al
c'est une aventure quoi je suis un
aventurier
donc aujourd'hui je vends des
calendriers
comme la moche de l'autre jour en
franchise à moosch la plus moche que les
autres au téléphone elle me dit on se
retrouve place des lilas pour se
reconnaître on aura chacun la main un
pare-chocs de combos
au début j'ai trouvé ça bizarre âge
mais rigolo donc je me suis pointé au
rendez vous et là j'ai compris pourquoi
m'avez demandé un parent chef de gang ou
parce qu'à part shot tu peux pas le
cacher si je vous assure quand j'ai vu
sa gueule j'ai voulu cacher impossible
âge et tu peux pas dire non non c'est
pas bien je crois par terre
j'ai pas tout non mais c'est vrai aussi
des questions qui m'empêche de dormir
les cadeaux avec nos enfants la fête des
pères des mères sur lamentable à s'y
attendait on va pas se mentir
pourquoi les colliers de nouilles
parce qu'ils savent pas faire autre
chose parce qu'on les protège trop un
petit pays asiatique à 5 ans il peut te
fermes et aux scop ou démasqué voix
jean-luc lemoine est inquiétant
maman et que tu en voilà
la semaine dernière on a fait une
nouvelle interview qu'on l'a testée sur
emmanuelle béart et josiane balasko une
interview impossible ça s'appelle
l'interview up saïda voici donc
l'interview
ap side à leur tour
[Musique]
jean luc lemoine quels sont les défauts
que doit avoir une femme pour vous
séduire les défauts
beaucoup de mauvais esprit et une
poitrine un peu trop grosse à l'acide
qui vous a fait le plus plaisir
ah ben il ya trois jours j'étais en
spectacle et pendant que je jouais ya
quelqu'un qui a dit dans la salle il est
horrible
il est horrible ça ça me fait plaisir
parce qu'elle a rigolé après la personne
mais bon si c'était sur mon physique ça
fait de la peine mais si c'était pour le
spectacle ça me fait plaisir
le compliment qui vous énerve le plus
c'est quand les gens me disent dans la
rue à je vous adore franchement je
trouve aussi drôle que gérard muller
vous avez des enfants
non j'en ai pas quand vous en aurez qu
est ce que vous aimeriez qu'il rate le
concours d'entrée la pop star
que leur interdire y est vous que vous
ne vous interdis sied pas à vous même du
coucher avec ma femme
pour quelles raisons
seriez vous capable de refuser votre
plus belle histoire d'amour parce que ça
craint je vais quand même pas me marier
avec ma mère un jeu quel est le talent
que vous n'aimeriez pas avoir de super
bien préparé les tripes c'est ça je m'en
fous un petit peu donc non ça ça
m'intéresse pas vraiment quelle est la
blague de votre spectacle vous fait pas
rire c'est celle qu'on a vue dans
l'extrait sur les petits enfants qui
préparent enfin les pays asiatiques qui
préparent des magnétoscopes et des
baskets la blague me fait rire mais le
font pas du tout ouais par qui m
l'auriez-vous être détesté par le mec de
liv tyler
ah ouais j'aime bien qui me déteste et
qu'il ait des raisons me détester quelle
phrase ne dites-vous jamais tient
aujourd'hui j'ai très bien un disque
delory
d'accord il a édulcoré le propos tu as
changé le nom parce qu'elle est là qu
est ce que vous aimeriez qu'on vous
volent à porter liz de sébastien manger
un peu de sérieusement qui m'a offert
ainsi en porcelaine à noël un jardin
comme le vol avant que loquace quelques
mythes marianne drôle george bush
qu'avez-vous fait délibérément à votre
insu alors là j'ai délibérément pas
compris la question là bas si vous
voulez en venir
natacha bas tout ce que ma conscience
m'interdirais à et voilà c'est fait
avoir encore
vos brass big santé
jean-louis quelle est la meilleure
mauvaises critiques qu'on vous ait fait
à une fois j'ai un j'ai un type qui est
sortie du spectacle plein milieu du
spectacle il a vu mon équipe et leur a
dit c'est honteux autant de cynisme sa
cause de spectacle comme ça qui a guère
ouais j'ai trouvé ça un peu excessif que
j'ai trouvé ça joli
la dernière question qu'il faut pas que
je vous pose sinon qu'ils achètent et
font reculer
alors quelques mails avant de nous
séparer
monsieur v richaud de dieppe est ce que
jean-luc la différents luc lemoine c'est
sûr
eh bien on va dire oui pour lui faire
plaisir karine cicurel de marseille
elle est fan de vous et les fans aussi
des chiffres et des lettres et dit ceci
explique cela
elle a dit qu'elle s'est amusé deux
secondes avec les lettres de votre nom
et vous savez ce qu'on peut faire avec
toutes les lettres de votre nom je sais
qu'on peut dire faire un truc comme
j'encule lemoine des photographes
[Musique]
il
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh la honte
bon ben on a besoin
bonsoir
la durée sa vaillance et joey starr
qu'elle adore et chutant et jérôme le
banner bonsoir bonsoir ça va vous
passiez dans le quartier là ouais ça à
temps et du mur c'était bien vous êtes
bien ici alors joe et comment ça va
aller voir jamel debbouze au casino de
paris hier soir ça ça vous a plu
ouais c'est ça ça vous a fait rire assez
way m'a fait participer un peu allez
voir ce que vous êtes monté sur scène
non non non mon manager ou pas alors
jérôme bernard bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
le numéro mondial de kahone le cas one
c'est de la boxe thaï pratiqué par des
gens assez assez corpulent alors se rend
souvent assez peureux me dit ça arrive
ça lorsqu'on appelle des chiottes tout à
feu alors le box set à rien et provoquer
des clashs le box et à utiliser pied ces
points ses genoux c'est oui griffe
souvent le cinéma tuèrent aussi le
ceinture mais justement le cas one donc
ça c'est des arts martiaux pratiqués par
des gens de plus de 90 kg 1
vous y tient un sport violent c'est
animal ça sent le fauve dans l'arène
c'est vrai alors les participants
s'affrontent pendant toute l'année à
travers des épreuves éliminatoires
et puis en décembre il ya la finale des
huit meilleurs au japon là vous défiler
en europe puis en maillot
ces interviews suicide
jérôme c'est un sport très populaire est
prise si tu savais qu'on avait presque
personne n'est pas m des trucs
incroyables 0 c'est un sport qui est
très populaire dans le monde entier qui
est de plus en plus répandu en france
même si les médias en parlent pas
beaucoup
battre un peu ou pas sont pas sots
apprenez les grands sports en tennis
ouais hein mais c'est un grand sport
enfin oui il ya des gens qui aiment bien
on va regarder à quoi ça ressemble
[Musique]
bah
m
gbagbo
[Musique]
il
voilà c'est le cas web
70 sa magnifique laurent septembre comme
d'abord tous ne traite pas tu as le
temps de premier truc parce que dois-je
fait matin coup de boule dans l'anus
depuis ça ne m'impressionne pas du tout
c'est que des prises connu des coups de
genoux une démonstration apprendrait
deux trois trucs après tu vas être
étonné d'être jeté
jérôme lecat one tiers des anciennes
stars de la boxe comme mike tyson que
vous allez rencontrer en automne aux usa
alors au début il ya de la boxe anglaise
donc là c'est un peu plus dur pour 6,1
pour le moins le problème est qu'il veut
mais il veut me rencontrer
alors aux états unis ça fera pas parce
que la commission athlétique le touriste
pas au japon mystère le premier ministre
s'y oppose donc monnaie reste plus que
paris ouais donc il veut plonger encore
eu ce matin c'est mieux les matchs en a
tout quitté hawaï là ils vont en boxe
anglaise moi j'ai dit oui après en
stipulant dans contrat que bon il faut
qu'ils me donnent aussi ma chance dans
mes michaels d'arrêt parce que si c'est
uniquement de la boxe anglaise ça va
être très dur pour vous s'il ya du kawa
mieux peut-être que peut-être partir
comme sont fourbes
le problème avec tyson c'est qu'il faut
boxer que des caches oreilles parce que
je n'avais qua non mais là j'ai pas
jupons de son courage il vous fait pas
peur du tout craché tout des gens sages
n 12 non non non non non non non si je
dois ce nom j'adore j'adore marquer avec
vous pour vous mettre ko sur un feu aux
poudres avec un tractopelle non non non
j'ai pris des trois ans des bosses ben
moi je me suis excusé c'est bon
allez
alors jérôme le banner donc votre surnom
c'est geronimo 1 né le 26 décembre 72 au
havre 1 mètre 90 120 kg et vous êtes
tombés dans les arts martiaux à ces
jeunes
vous avez fait d'abord du judo ensuite
du karaté du full contact et en 98 vous
cédez à la pelle de john king le fameux
manager de boxe et vous rejoignez son
écurie de boxe pour faire de la broderie
et il s'entraîne avec le coach de lille
field à l'époque donc c'est puis c'est
plutôt bien et alors john king à
l'époque il veut faire vraiment de vous
le comité de l'espoir blanc dans la boxe
quoi c'est avec eux jean christophe
courrèges enfin que le départ donc 95
dont je suis sorti donc donc des arts
martiaux pour aller justement dans la
dent dans le cloud après donc je suis
passé donc la boxe anglaise boxe
anglaise lui pensait voir l'espoir mans
- le japon ça manquait lé coup de pied
le coup de poing sattouf à sa fin ça a
tout manqué un ou deux chercheurs trop
aimer d'amour retourner aux arts
martiaux vous étiez trop influencée par
bruce lee pour laisser tomber jean
claude van damme ou si tout cela est
vrai alors c'est une super star au japon
la centaine sur les paquets de bientôt
car sur les vous avez fait une pub pour
des rouges à lèvres au japon alors pour
mieux se connaître on va voir ce que
vous avez fait dans la vie ce que vous
avez pas fait on va faire une interview
fait aux affaires
castilla dit la durée je dis bon courage
alors vous répondez fait ou à faire une
nuit avec de geisha à faire avant un
débat philosophique avec jean claude van
damme a fait un scrabble avec joey starr
a fait une piqûre avant un combat
a fait fait ouais c'est fait c'est fait
j'avais mal au genou et ben on m'a piqué
like the wind
on va vérifier un la terre sont des
thalys entre joue en chu z'eux une
chaussette dans votre short pour
impressionner les fans à faire vous
faire casser la gueule par un mec d'un
mètre soixante déjà fait déjà fait
et que ton appli iphone cette affiche
les français nous servons des couilles
culture accepté de vous coucher pour de
l'argent robert rappelle toi non je
prends comme on a jeté l'épongé en plein
combat qui vous non les proches qui est
un drame on la fait encore mais y'a
plein de trucs que vous avez à faire
alors ça je vois même un bras cassé ont
été jetés pour les tronches donc c'est
négatif pour moi çà ou là lol faut pas
l'emmerder le nom mais jérôme faut pas
l'emmerder sa séquestration
[Musique]
alors si on met toutes vos entrées sur
le ring sur la musique de joey starr et
vous joey starr avec dadou vous avez
fait la musique un certain nombre de
morceaux du nouveau film d'alain chabat
qui s'appelle voilà donc avec les robins
jean rochefort gérard depardieu et vous
joey starr ouais je suis une apparition
mi temps c'est bien la musique que vous
avez fait si c'est à ces dates du café
ça
[Musique]
oh
voilà c'est donc pour le film d'alain
chabat avec les robins on en parlera
plus longuement la la semaine prochaine
avec alain chabat et jean paul rouve
alors c'est génial victoire c'est un
policier préhistorique complètement
nonsense c'est assez génial et vougeot
les stars vous jouez vous faites les
seigneurs de gourdins ne change pas trop
mais fait sens
c'est pas un rôle de composition
finalement ça s'est bien passé le
tournage ou à mort pour moi c'était très
courant soir duroueix je pense être une
dizaine de minutes
ouais j'suis pas chaude à eddy cue bombe
n'a fait très vite quoi on était bien
ouais sur moi est vraiment illégal film
tu l'as lu non bah ouais ben façon je
suis venu un peu le vent donc je veux
pas dire qu'il pouvait non plus la
raison que j avais pas pensé
les gens qui viennent pas dire ça va
puis je suis pas chabal rba moi c'est un
style de prédilection
alors vous dadou vous étiez tavares dans
gomez et tavarès les fameux ripoux j'ai
adoré ça vous le savez d'ailleurs
maintenant ils sont devenus gomes et du
bois pourquoi vous êtes parti parce que
moi ça partait d'une
une intention assez assez saine et une
intention assez spontané et quand ils
devenus
une exploitation commerciale dans le bon
sens du terme
ça ne m'intéressait plus parce que
j'avais plus j'avais plus j'avais pu le
spontané qui avait au départ mais il est
pas mal d'albums de ramasser du bois
n'en met pas moins il n'y a pas de
problème sur soi mais moi je me sentais
vraiment pas de quoi enfin vous sentez
pas de mentir en ouais alors dadou après
de nombreux featurings vous avez fait un
premier album en avril 2003 qui
s'appelle france history x c'est sur
l'intégration
aujourd'hui et vous dit que finalement
l'intégration aujourd'hui c'est des
petites histoires
c'est exactement et c'est dans le dans
le texte
je décris un peu une famille française
moyenne avec un fichier cue du rap une
fille qui sort avec ali qui est qui fait
le ramadan qui fait le ramadan est pour
moi l'intégration elle passe par ces
petites choses là le poste par deux
histoires d'amour des fois elle passe
par plein de petites choses qui en font
des grandes
c'est vrai qu'en fait vous dit que
maintenant les jeunes ils savent ce que
c'est le ramadan chaque nuit je là
dedans
messieurs finalement il a pu la
télévision qui ne ne sais pas comment ça
se passe quoi je proposerai je pense
vraiment toute la nuit et le continue à
se faire dans la rue avec des gens
et au jour le jour et qu'aujourd'hui
synthétiser l'information à des faits
divers et en faire une
une peinture sociale c'est un peu
s'éloigner de la réalité
alors votre prochain album va sortir
cette année oui je pense
vous viendrez nous en parler j'espère
bien mais j'espère bien on peut y donner
une carte
voilà très bien merci bien quand vous
revenez quand vous voulez vous alors
vous dites complète mon rêve c'est le
jazz
mon inspiration au niveau du flou c'est
mal ce délice
vous pensez à aller plus vers le jazz
dans l'avenir - vers le rap
disons que je pense à faire beaucoup
plus de musique en général et de et de
vraiment démontré que le rap ça a été
comment dire la musique de mon époque 20
et que et que je respecte vraiment est
ce qui s'est passé avant parce qu'il a
une histoire avant le rap on peut
arriver et prétendre révolutionner
quelque chose donc c'est vraiment faire
le relais entre ce qui s'est passé et ce
qui se passera quoi alors joey comment
ça va vous savez que les gens vous
aiment de plus en plus vous êtes de plus
est vous êtes bientôt dans le top 50 des
français préféré des français vous savez
ça je suis pas je capital sympathie moi
c'est toi mon truc énorme capital
sympathie et je vous dis qu'on fasse une
interview qui vous montre si votre
meilleur jour vas-y je suis je suis pour
je me suis réveillée alors si tu t'es
réveillé pour ça donc allons-y
l'interview fleur bleue
[Musique]
joey starr à l'interview fleur bleue est
ce que vous croyez au coup de foudre jo
et ouais ouais
est ce que vous étiez timide la première
fois on met toujours en dessous elle
s'appelait comment la première s'en
souvenait pas tout de suite
ouais est ce que vous l'avez est ce que
vous l'avez écrire un poème au moins
j'aurai n'ont même pas non pour
regretter est ce que vous demandez
conseil à votre meilleure amie en cas de
peine de coeur
non c'est pas comme ça que c'est comme
ça que ça se passe on normalement oui on
en voit des fables bien sûr moment enfin
j'en parle mais ouais mais au conseil ne
vous demandez pas conseil banon est ce
que vous aimez effeuiller les
marguerites je t'aime beaucoup
passionnément à la folie pas du tout
marc marquez vélo là
adieu et on fait quoi pour la
saint-valentin jeu
j'envoie des fleurs à botmeur à votre
mère c'est tout bon a quelques uns des
autres sites web à merde principalement
d'accord vous offrez des roses rouges
n'ont pas votre mère ouais si je me
rende ma mère donc ouais un niveau cinq
ans parle un joueur ça vous dirait jo et
des violons sur votre prochain disque
c'est quoi la question c'est vrai que tu
penses à faire une reprise et petit
bonhomme en mousse ou
qui sait
hélas
ces vols
lachance
et maintenant
oui
si christine deviers joncour
[Musique]
magnifique christine deviers-joncour
c'est du coin ça du lapin à le portugal
[Musique]
là
oh
c'est le attentes et a servi offert la
petite veste comment ça va bah ça va pas
mal
piscine de 10 en cours dont on vous a
connu [ __ ] de la république à l essai
nous on vous a connu chanteuse et
maintenant vous êtes écrivain non mais
j'ai écrite 97,5 m
on la suit l'annoncé de sa romance à
rendre c'est un roman les autres c'était
pour les affaires au moins un outil
complet pour me défendre nous battre là
on souffle on parle d'autre chose
parlant mal au cul on parle de cul de
labriffe iwuy christine vous êtes une
vraie touche à tout non alors avant de
passer aux livres qui vous amène que les
signes de les gens courent quand même
faire le point sur les activités
précédentes donc [ __ ] de la république
effectivement vous regrettez d'ailleurs
et vous le dit assez souvent de ne pas
avoir intitulé le livre
[ __ ] de république mais [ __ ] ou les
maquereaux de la république j'ai eu tort
bien alors ensuite christine on vous a
connu chanteuse et là on a découvert
avec stupeur au moment de la sortie du
disque que toute votre enfance j'ai
travaillé le piano avec un grand
musicien espagnol qui avait fui le
franquisme qui s'était réfugié à sarlat
et que normalement vous auriez dû être
christine deviers-joncour chef
d'orchestre compositeur
voilà comme bien fini sa carrière elle a
toujours mené les hommes à la baguette
de toute façon
ces jeunes oui cela j'ai pas qui a mené
la vie c'est dur de commencer à 55 ans
pour une jeune chanteuse pourquoi vous
dites mon âge je dîne mieux on a nagé
vous êtes en avoir des poils blancs
n'est pas de la première pour vous
pensez à quoi vous pensez quoi
sérieusement festive en pensez quoi de
ces nouveaux chanteurs qui ne savent pas
chanter qui vendent des millions
d'albums
alors que vous en vendez beaucoup moins
vous savez pas chanter en plus je sais
pas je ne sais pas chanter je crois que
d'abord j'ai eu envie de décrire c'est
une sage m'exprimer c'est ce qui m'a
motivé en même temps la musique j'ai
toujours baigné est bon si ça marche ça
marche
moi je me fais plaisir c'est le
principal ne croyez pas vous auriez dû
chanter pour ceux qui sont loin de chez
eux qu'ils ont dans les yeux quelque
chose qui fait mal
j'ai pensé vous regrettez pas voir avec
les votre chance en vous même mais je
les écris moi même ça tu regrettes pas
t'as pas écouté l'album je le dire après
que je les écoute deux fois par an et
non il est pas sorti parce que
berger un secret je l'écoutais la bonne
vitesse et on recommence alors donc un
[ __ ] de la république deux chanteuses
trois écrivains un livre après un indice
que voulait vraiment on est en prison
christine non parce que là j'ai ris
coréen parce que là ça parle pas d'
affaire d'état par rapport à votre place
si vous auriez pas mieux fait de sortir
une ligne de chaussures nous ça
m'intéresse pas vous n'êtes plus associé
alors le livre s'appelle comme le disent
que toi masculin mon féminin c'est aux
éditions du rocher
et c'est ennuyant érotique alors vous
dites j'ai écrit ce livre pour ne pas
mourir
au lendemain du procès en appel après la
relaxe d'humains en voyant que je
prenais encore les coûts qui est vrai
que j'ai passé quelques mois très durs
j'avais plus tellement de death d'avenir
dans l'essex ouvert ce membre tuméfié
semble prendre naissance et voilages et
la gaule bravo
j'ai alors c'est l'histoire d'une femme
à la dérive qui vit encore dans le
souvenir du grand amour de sa vie
le grand amour de sa vie c'est un homme
plus âgé qui l'a marqué à jamais mais
qu'il l'a jamais épousé etc est mort
roland dumas est mort non c'est pas
j'avais passé donc je peux pas caché qu
effectivement l'héroïne je me suis
complètement week end bien sûr parce que
j'avais aussi à travers à travers celle
j'avais besoin de lire des choses
donc effectivement et aussi peut-être
j'ai voulu montrer une femme une femme
qui s'est battu et a pris des sacré coup
dans la gueule
et cette femme se retrouve dans ce grand
amour dans canal que rien avec cet homme
elle n'a plus rien n'est complètement
acquérir et elle retombe amoureux
voilà alors demain qui au départ est
très macho et on découvre rapidement que
c'est une folle tordue balle si
convaincant exigent la clé c'est lui
adore se travestir
c'est un jeu c'est certain on a tous en
nous du masculin du fidjien tournoi en
donnes moi j'ai peut-être fait féminine
je crois que j'ai beaucoup de masculin
en moi et je me suis dit en écrivant ce
que j'avais besoin de vivre une histoire
d'amour que je vis pas c'est vrai je
suis un peu seul depuis sept ans et je
me suis immergé là dedans et je me suis
dit voyons quel est le genre d'homme qui
pourrait me faire me faire peut-être
attendre étaient imaginaires ne soit
l'inversé de moi c'est à dire à la fois
masculins et féminins jouer sur les
présentations sont venus sur féret a
déjà fait tomber dans le 9 3 c'est quoi
le 9 3 ah oui et banlieues ne sera plus
là maintenant je suis pas allé mes
entraîneurs
je connais personne dans la visite qui
va connaître du monde très bien et bon
donnera une autre niche aussi une page
donc c'est un soir glace et de pleine
lune donc oui vous êtes vous êtes avec
le dieu s'est arrangé alors elle se
déshabille derrière un four il fait très
froid il fait fonction de ta part je
venais à lui dévêtue voilà et alors je
ne craignais plus froids de mort qu'ils
agissaient comme une douleur
j'avançais encore j'imagine le spectacle
qui s'offrait à lui je jubilais à un
mètre de lui je m'arrêter il s'approcha
haute à sa vareuse qu'il posa à même le
sol sur l'herbe givré ces imams 1 et
l'invita et m'invite à m'allonger
j'obéis son corps mais recouvre y sans
aucun préliminaire il écarta mais en
tout cas c'est bien conjuguer parce que
les kartings mes jambes ce qui nous
laisse lire les cartes à ce mes jambes
tout est bien conjuguer en tout cas
d'avoir tort à sa ceinture brutale comme
un viol je senti ça que red me pénétrer
écarter les chères comme une déchirure
son désir était violent un patient ces
coups de boutoir
ces coups de boutoir rouaix tout
au fond de mon ventre voilà voilà ça
c'est la mort du vieux quoi pratiquer
vous devez tuer et donc effectivement
après cette aventure avec ce cet homme
disant d'un âge mûr
l'héroïne est complètement déboussolée
elle prête à quitter paris et la
rencontre le fameux francesco qui est un
riche businessman
alors il ya un truc que je supporte pas
c'est qu'il est fier de frauder le fisc
c'est une image annonce est pas une
image
moi je trouve que c'est pas bien pour
les spas pierre de fautes et les filles
si je dis je raconte que
qu'effectivement il est comme beaucoup
c'est à dire 20 % de français
aujourd'hui qui se demandent comment ils
vont faire et qui s'est délocalisé le 15
vous dites la réussite qu'il faut
planquer sous peine de délit d'abus de
biens sociaux
c'est pas vrai quand sur l'argent propre
sur lequel on a payé ses impôts on peut
s'acheter tout ce qu'on veut en france
ce qui est interdit
acheter des trucs explosion de la
société 6 am je croise ici c'est très
simple faire payer des impôts
chanter est toute ma vie pour moi ça va
à quelqu'un ça aide les gens oui ça fait
d'écraser les hôpitaux non sérieuses
avancées mais c'est vrai qu'il faut
c'est vrai qu'il ya des gens que je me
paye des impôts et je bénéficie pas de
certaines choses comme un citoyen normal
quoi
j'appelle la police c'est pas la même
histoire ils viennent quand ils
n'appellent pas de problème
non mais quand je vis la réussite qu'il
faut planquer sous peine de délit d'abus
de biens sociaux
c'est pas vrai quand on peut s'acheter
ce qu'on veut avec l'argent dit est
propre
aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui montrent une
entreprise qui a acquis à la force du
poignet pendant des années la montre et
sa propre entreprise à créer de l'emploi
et qui moi c'était ça n'arrive j'entends
ça autour de moi tous les jours et qui
achètent je sais pas j'exagère mais un
billet d'avion pour les vacances et de
la bbc la chaussée sa propre entreprise
et c'est normal c'est ça les gens font
c'est qu'ils s'en aillent cela parce que
je vais vous dire ça c'est de l'abus de
bien social effectivement s'acheter des
billets d'avion reprendre pour aller en
vacances sur les frais de la société
c'est pour ça c'est un délit c'est un
abus de bien social et c'est interdit et
c'est normal voilà
je bave et les délais sont morts enfin
quand même énormément les gens ne
connaissent pas tout ça ils demandent
même pour des petites distances même
pour le net positif si c'est pas
professionnel on paye avec son pote
d'accès comme c'est vrai que ça m'a paru
dernière flat qui s'en vont et qui selon
moi j'ai rien compris ce qui s'est dit
mais qu'ils sont mais on s'en fout canap
la voilà nous reste non vraiment je suis
là voilà bon alors elle baise avec
francesco donc alors vous dites un amant
reprise juste martineau alléger un peu
roberto d eau
c'est vous qui avez écrit un bouquin
c'est pas moi alors ils vont en vacances
ensemble et là il devra porter des sous
vêtements féminins race est
effectivement le mec était c'est assez
chaud là quelle page quelle page 82 je
suis en paix ne se fait plus rageuse et
secoue la palmeraie les partenaires du
musée de jasmin sont enivrantes effluves
le tissu s'envole parce que le mec a mis
la nuit soit réduit de l'emploi dans la
métaphore religieuse
les parfums de mer du musée de jasmin
sont des livres en effluves le tissu
s'envole découvrant sa nudité jusqu'à la
taille du mec en retombant tout en
plaquant la soie sur son ventre
le pan de la chemise s'accroche sur son
sexe tendue qu'il laisse ainsi offert
commune assure une provocation choqué
choisi est déjà assez bien à ce stade là
on voit pas encore la bip aider mais ils
écoutent pas je ne résiste pas une
tentation brutal nous dit que sin
deviers joncour devant lui je
m'agenouille tous attendent même mes
mains à travers le vêtement de pau
d'enjeu les fleurs du bout des doigts
qu'est-ce que s'agir elite est dessiné
sous le velouté du tissu le public
mexique davantage alors ça va jusqu'au
dîner à la fin il ya un dîner où il
arrive
qui est le mec me pousse à l'extrême
mais pourrez vous immerger grippe a et
les mecs arrivent maquiller riches note
avec un porte jarretelles parce que je
trouve ça aussi
techcite 0 c'est ma mère mais ça va
saigner des pistes
les appels à la fin donc il faut un
dîner fin le mec se maquille il met un
porte jarretelles
il se couche par terre c'est des idées
pour vous avec ares avec votre canadien
et l'on vous dit ni feu mais nous y
sommes
les cuisses serre et le sexe des mesures
est offert c'est que la mesure de la
mensuration c'est tout le temps il lui
dit prends moi ma chérie donc mais qui
est précédée dialogue et alors ces
moments où ils l'attachent magie elle
mouille son doigt pour titiller c'est ça
le le bout de ses seins du mec je
m'emballe sur ce pieux démesurée qui me
déchire le ventre c'est toujours
levantin sait jamais la chatte c'est
bizarre bon allez le docu jeanine cela
dépend même pas parce que c'est très
très chaude si lafarge plie en trois
heures hyper chaud j'avais le cul la
mine est calciné est incrusté d'une
épaisse croûte noire
alors je trouve
c'est
revis à les envahir
j'avais effectivement eu la mine et
helsinn est incrusté d'une épaisse
croûte morts ça c'est la version bossa
nova mais s'il s'agit des casseroles
[Applaudissements]
voilà
je suis bien différent q donc servir
eux-mêmes et tous les aveyronnais
casserole
[Musique]
alors c'est quoi christine sérieusement
même si je sais c'est quoi pour vous
l'homme idéal sérieusement j'y crois
plus à l'homme idéal
c'est un rêve ça de chagrin d'amour et
je me suis créé une histoire comme ça et
en écrivant j'ai vécu quelque chose et
j'ai oublié le reste les affaires de la
couleur de cheveux de l'homme idéal pour
vous brun la coupe de jeu fun tu m'en
fous un peu plus trapu
je voulais lui mais même comme ça je
voulais qu'il soit musclé jusque là fois
surtout face à rennes pas musclé me bat
mais très musclé vague à tous les
si vous voulez qu'ils soient beaux
enfants qu'ils aient de l'argent je m'en
fous quel bord politique voulait qu'ils
soient qui fait qu'ils soient d'aucun
bord bien au centre
rien du tout religion je m'en fous la
première chose que l'homme idéal dois
vous dire en se levant au revoir
là la dernière chose que l'homme idéal
dois vous dire avant de s'endormir
je sais pas j'ai encore envie de toi à
la plus belle preuve d'amour qu'il
puisse vous donner être là dans les
coups durs
oui ce n'était pas le cas de comment il
s'appelait jaffe au fait l'homme idéal
il doit chausser du combien
piscine de méchant pour la vie ne vous a
pas épargné
on va voir l'expérience que vous en avez
tiré on va faire une interview ardilouze
vous avez raté quand même soit votre
permis de conduire j'ai eu du premier
coup
18 ans la tenue la plus moche que vous
ayez jamais porté par le coup du lapin
mais là le pire émissions de tv et
xavier fait c'est pas chez vous vous
aurez la chance est gentil le plus
mauvais livres que vous ayez jamais lui
livre le dernier de roland dumas a le
dernier de roland dumas
ah oui vous a pas plu comment on
s'appelle je suis même plus j'oublie je
sais même plus obama s'est aussi bien il
n'y avait pas et une mère un appareil le
plus mauvais livres que vous ayez écrit
le premier 1
la [ __ ] d'incurie la personne qui vous
a fait le plus de mal on va pas leur
cité tout le temps c'est lui je crois en
page 22
[Musique]
sur le haut
je vais vous laisser filer natacha si
les deux sens hier
oui bien entendu c'est quoi vous vous
reconnaissez merci
[Applaudissements]
et y en a un autre qui va arriver
j'accueille ali labhar est calme
[Musique]
voir ali lamrabet banque tient
simplement une petite démonstration
parce que ouais c'est gentil
tu as vu comme il est gentil et à vrai
dire il m'a laissé gagner tant pis pour
la zac
alors nous on est heureux parce que vous
êtes libre à qui tu parles
donc oui le drame est condamné à quatre
ans de prison ferme pour outrage au roi
mohamed 6 en mai dernier
vous venez d'être graciés le 7 janvier
après sept mois et demi de détention à
la prison de rabat voilà alors merci
mohamed 6 merci reporter sans frontières
qui a fait beaucoup pour vous et
d'ailleurs je vais en profiter pour
montrer le livre de reporter sans
frontières c'est l'album d'helmut newton
qui est vendue au profit de cette
association qui lutte pour la défense de
la liberté d'information dans le monde
sans frontières d'ailleurs robert ménard
était lui manifester avec d'autres de
reporter sans frontières à courchevel
devant le chalet du roi mohamed 6 avec
des fumigènes rouges des tee-shirts
rouges alors vous étiez directeur de
deux hebdos satiriques marocain un qui
s'appelle demain l'autre qui s'appelle
duman qui est en langue arabe se dire
quoi duman demain ouais non arabes les
fautes qui vous ont été reprochés à
lille c'est d'abord j'ai discuté la
liste civile royal c'est l'argent qui
est attribuée par l'état marocain au roi
pour son train de vie liste civile qui a
été voté par le parlement
on pensait que c'était trop d'argent
sans doute nous on a juste dit que les
honorables députés de la nation de
indiscuté jamais de
ce silence et en angleterre par exemple
et puis on a juste dit qu'il y avait
peut-être un député qui trouvait que
cette liste était pas assez suffisante
qui voudrait dire ajoute un petit peu
ouais et donc ils nous ont dit que ça
s'était outrage au roi et puis voilà
donc ça veut dire alors deuxième chose
vous avez interviewé un activiste
républicain marocain voit la troisième
chose vous avez fait un photomontage à
partir d'une photo officielle du mariage
de mohamed 6 voilà au web un goûter et
l'équipe va gracier pascal saint-amans
ça de vrai ça devenait vraiment ridicule
de mettre quelqu'un en prison pour deux
dessins puis un article mais bon moi ce
qui m'étonne c'est qu'ils bon c'est que
c'est que l'entourage du roi parce que
je pense pas que ce soit le roi ait pris
autant de temps pour se rendre compte
que c'est vraiment une situation
ridicule comme vous comme moi c'est ça
alors apparemment vous croyez pas à la
volonté de démocratisation de mohamed 6
écoutez moi je pour y croire nous ne
faut un projet moi je ne vois aucun
projet il avait même fait une commission
qui s'appelle équité et réconciliation
pour régler donc les problèmes qui a eu
du temps de son père hassan ii ce qu'on
appelle les années de plomb pour éviter
des problèmes de violation des droits de
l'homme quand même là il ya des gens il
ya disons qu'il faut voir aussi les les
noms parce que nous on vit sur place si
on voit les les noms qui sont les noms
de gens qui n'en sont membres de cette
fameuse cette fameuse choses parce que
je sais pas si on peut l'appeler une
commission honorable et qui bon bain
sont tous pratiquement moi je n'aurai
pas tous pour ce qui est des gens
honorables général sont pratiquement
tous des récupérer ce sont des gens qui
y croyaient pas quoi écouter dès qu'il
est là depuis depuis pratiquement 5
combien de biens pillés de sa vie de
cinq ans et je vois pas ce que ça a
changé - moi mais bon qu'est ce que j'ai
droit maintenant aujourd'hui aux marques
de 2004 de dire je ne crois pas j'y
crois pas des cas c'est à ces
changements parce qu'il ya peu de
changements en fin de compte il ya juste
des dd gestique voilà qu'on a vu on m'a
libéré un serial
ou alors vous êtes en france pour vous
soigner 1 suite à une grève de la faim
que vous avez fait en prison mais vous
comptez retourner au maroc et republié à
ce moment là des journaux satiriques
vous dites mon combat est là bas oui oui
c'est parce que moi je ne fais rien de
mal
moi je ne suis ni un assassin moi j'ai
pas de compte en banque en suisse je
n'ai pas volé l'argent l'argent l'argent
des critiques n'a pas de compte en
banque en suisse voilà moi j'ai pas ça
ah non mais c'était pas pour ça c est ce
que vous souhaitez la chute de la
monarchie marocaine absolument pas moi
je suis même pas républicain lorrain
souvenez vous quand même du syndrome
iranien c'est à dire que tout le monde
tapait sur le shah d'iran
c'était devenu vraiment l'épouvantail
numéro un mondial et puis après on a eu
on a eu comme eni on a eu les mots là on
a eu la république islamique et et
finalement on a quitté un régime
autoritaire pour un régime totalitaire
donc on peut se demander finalement t-il
départ de mohamed 6 arrangerait quelque
chose au maroc
non mais franchement ce que vous croyez
que deux petites publication satirique
vont vraiment un bâtard régime qui a une
mode et qu'il est là depuis depuis
pratiquement quatre siècles
moi je sais pas gérer en france à la
pollution ça a commencé et les libelles
ça commençait que des pamphlets ca
commence avec des choses comme ça si
vous me donner ce pouvoir nombreux jeux
maintenant maintenant maintenant je vais
essayer je t'écoute
ça l'est vraiment ses 7,7 à pouvoir que
je n'ai pas 20 g passe me voir parce que
ça lui aujourd'hui le roi du maroc est
le dernier rempart contre l'islamisme au
maroc
est ce que vous croyez que c'est malin
de le démolir de le démolit pas mais moi
je pense que le dernier rempart contre
les islamistes et la démocratie c'est ça
c'est la démocratie dit que le mot c'est
un mot magique si on a pas de démocratie
mais bientôt on va voir les islamistes
c'est sûr et s'il ya des islamistes et
que quelque chose ne fonctionne pas dans
le système marocain c'est pas mes
journaux c'est le système indique marca
bill est là il fonctionne il fonctionne
pas et puis tout ce qu'on voit c'est
qu'on voit que les islamistes remonte
lentement trop lentement le monde et moi
pas parce que j'ai il ya de publication
satirique hommes se livrent pas mode
parce qu'il ya un problème mais pour ça
on remarquait des élections à une
audition lui mais bon après les
dernières élections
les deux des femmes aux élections
législatives de 2002 on n'a pas encore
les chiffres exacts
j'aurais étudiants sont venus parler d'
ali mrabet ah ouais non complètement
courageux quand maintenant et coûteux
d'aller dans nos placards pour ses idées
déjà un beau en plus c'est franchement
qu'il a fait j'ai l'impression que maroc
des trois pays d'afrique du nord ça a
l'air d'être loupé plus libérale quoi on
se rend compte que pas tant que ça quoi
finalement quoi et puis que un peu comme
chez nous quoi c'est toujours la poudre
aux yeux finalement est-ce que ça vous a
fait peur maintenant vous y allez un peu
freiné ou au contraire vous y allez
encore plus mais vous savez moi je
cherche juste de l'information comme le
fait
le fond d'eux les journaux satiriques
français je rajoute un peu d'humour et
puis voilà il y avait un dessin et
justement si on peut revendre et ça
justement ceux des syndicats étaient
considérés comme subversifs
il ya trois mares et puis le juge il m'a
dit l'une des trois mains
vendu 2,3 main celle de roy avait coûté
un peu plus à moi laquelle voila voila
c'est tout misé me werner faymann et qui
fait ses devoirs la masse et la liste
civile du roi au parlement connecte les
doigts du roi là au milieu kaka
moustache
qu'est ce qui va se passer donc là je
vais repartir maroc quand partir dans
deux semaines toujours
et puis je vais déposer
je vais pas bon avait déposé deux
demandes de deux journaux et puis je
vais voir et si vous les donner à abbas
il me donne pas et alors ça ça veut dire
qui violent la loi c'est pas la première
fois qu'ils viennent la loi mais ça
c'est vraiment flagrant si si par
exemple à moi je pense que mohamed six
enfants tous les cas djamel me l'a dit
ils regardent souvent tout le monde en
parle regardez votre caméra si vous avez
quelque chose à lui dire c'est le moment
je dirais majesté moi je ne suis pas je
ne suis pas votre aîné mais moi je suis
un marocain
de plus ce qu'il veut de biens % pkoi et
au moins bref moi je voudrais avoir une
sécurité sociale si par exemple demain
je tombe malade le jeu je ne serais pas
obligé de venir en france pour me faire
soigner
j'ai envie de 2,2 de vivre normalement
et puis j'ai pas envie d'avoir des
islamistes je veux dire de barive et
beau pouvoir comme je pressens qui sont
en train de faire c'est tout et moi je
suis très respectueux du chef de l'état
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
et
jérôme g ou laisser filer aussi merci
nos vaillants et courageux besoin comme
le tarif viol
sur mon bureau
ça me fait mal toro beauté
ainsi olivier ciron et alexandra coulet
[Musique]
ça s'annonce très doux s'agit d'entrer
en libye où avec son mac ou les sponsors
de ces classes non il embrasse moi et
c'est vachement bien alors vous êtes
monsieur madame x bats l'avant temps de
parler
donc je vous ai déjà dîné avec greg et
marika le millionnaire monsieur madame
basterds a les dirigeants que vous
faites des quatre la famille le
millionnaire reçoit la famille de bâle
nord
non non non ça nous arrivait une fois en
fait on a fait une émission de télé on
est partis à l'étranger et donc on a dit
c'est ce qu'a encore des gens qui vous
demandent comment vous vous êtes
rencontrés
non franchement non john cassette vidéo
alors pêche là on connaît le principe un
célibataire bien sous tous rapports très
convoité qui est isolé dans une villa
entourée de 25 jeunes femmes prêtes à
tout pour lui plaire voilà et donc pour
mieux connaître les prétendantes
le bachelor nous invite à faire des
voyages et vous vous l'avait invité en
fait j'étais à vienne avoue que ça s'est
passé c'était le bal impériale à vienne
ça a été le grand moment de magie de
l'histoire
tu vois je vois bien sûr du mois c'est
d'ailleurs ce master grand bateau ni une
course de mammouth close
elle te plaît alexandre un secret trop
bien
alors évidemment alexandra vous savez
qu'en ce moment on parle beaucoup du
voile islamique qui est soi-disant le
symbole de la soumission de la femme
enfin le bachelor finalement c'est un
rêve non je comprends pas pourquoi ça
pourquoi les féministes qui s'en
prennent aux voiles islamiques s'en
prennent pas aux bachelor elles s'en
sont pris aux vaches normes on les a
moins entendu quand même
au début oui alors vous vous êtes
vraiment tombé amoureux c'est ça le
fruit clan avec sandra c'est ça a été ça
a été comme ge est il justement à vienne
le ballon derrière dans ce que vous avez
dit jamais quelqu'un ne m'avait regardé
comme ça
depuis je suis vraiment folle de lui un
verre
j'ai pas été influencé par le décorum
l'hôtel viennent
les violences non avec du recul ou afp
dans un formule 1 est ce que vous seriez
tombée amoureuse de non c'est pas ses
fans la chose qui nous influencent
ajuste une nouvelle fiancée connaître
dans une émission de télé réalité donc
dans un vase clos une aventure humaine
un peu particulière et peut-être que
pour nous ça a été super vite
les corses veulent aventure qui fait
quand même ça va très vite
alors vous aussi olivier parce qu'on
rend disait qu'alexandra était tombé
raide dingue de vous à vienne mais vous
aussi vous dites c'est la première fois
de ma vie où j'ai eu envie de prendre un
risque et vous l'avez pris est ce que
vous ne pensez pas avec sandra est ce
que vous pensez pas que vous avez fait
piéger un peu par la tv quand même non
du tout non mais j'étais là j'ai à
chaque cérémonie de la rose comme on
appelle ça j'avais le choix de partir il
j'ai décidé de rester moi j'aurais pu la
piéger ouest avec vous vous avez déclaré
quelques quelques mois avant le beh là
que vous en aviez marre des femmes plus
jeunes que vous pour avouer craqué sur
ard d'une part j'ai dit j'ai dit que
j'en avais marre des femmes plus jeunes
que vous donc je cherchais une femme
plus âgée et que en plus jamais les
femmes tuto voluptueux sens avec des
formes et c'est avec alexandra j'ai eu
tout faux quoi ça prouve bien que je
contrôle pas ce qui s'est passé que non
mais ça se voit en plus c'est pas ça se
voit même le même si dans une émission
télé arrêté il ya un montage ya tout ce
que tu veux
plein de gens qui l'ont vu moi qui m'ont
connu qui me connaissent ils ont dit
tout de suite c'est alexandra des
premières émissions ça se voie sacrée
volée aussi dans 60 jours 60 nuits ils
m'ont dit ouais c'est ton surface et sur
donc vous êtes tombé réellement amoureux
l'un de l'autre mais quand même c'est
après l'émission tout l'été vous étiez
comme ça souriant visite toutes les
couvertures de magazines petit couple
parfait qui vit dans son duplex en
rêvant d'avoir des enfants mais j'ai la
rage le conte de fées n'a pas duré bassi
parce que dans ce cas je pense qu'à on
ne cache pas que des problèmes parce que
par exemple alexandra vous savez qu
olivier ne supporte pas votre côté
bordélique
il vous trouve pas assez mature et vous
trouvez indécise replier sur vous même
pas très pro bass et indépendante passé
monde aime passer parisienne ont annoncé
ou des limites précis parce que je
souhaitais ici quand vous sortez par
exemple dans ces soirées people
non vous vous êtes assez tranquille il
va dire bonjour à tout le monde il veut
connaître tout le monde a besoin et ce
soir ce soir lui dans une semaine que je
veux dire par dix ans vous êtes moins
voilà c'est si vous êtes passé j'ai fait
assez mondaine c'est ce qui vous
reprendre ces pros nature un peu je
reproche passage je sais elle me
reproche justement de 2 dans les soirées
d'aller voir d'autres gens et c'est moi
je vous dis tout en nuançant bras on
nettoyé
oui on en arrive à la bise à tout le
monde tu peux pas être parfait dans le
coin comme que nous en fait great on
prouve qu'on est comme tout le monde tu
regardes par en fait il là reviennent à
l'aller les matchs à la télé pour la
chaîne en veut plus et c'est garanti ou
pas et je veux la garantie petit village
et bâtisseur mais c'est vrai aussi
faut dire aussi les choses dans l'autre
sens c'est vrai qu'alexandra a pas
apprécié quand tu étais arrivé chez vous
de trouver toutes les photos de vos ex
et puis ensuite je vais pas les détruire
j'ai refusé de de changer le décor
d'appartement alors c'était vraiment pas
refusé et je vais parpaings de l'ena
mais c'est une nouvelle vie qui commence
et olivier sessa mais on n'allait pas on
vient juste de se connaître
d'accord une pièce pour montrer pour
vous et pire que tout pire que tout vous
avez vous avez revu des ex candidate
c'est pas pire que tous ces décès défi
que j'ai rencontrés pendant l'émission
que j'ai apprécié qu'il est maintenant
il y avait quelque chose et voilà c'est
tout vrai non plus c'est pas les filles
avec qui avait qui s'est passé quelque
chose mais il va se passer avec sandra
vous vous regretter d'avoir quitté vos
parents et vos peluche pour tout ça
c'était facile non c'est sûr c'est pas
évident parce que j'ai changé j'ai
quitté toute ma vie du jour au lendemain
mais je regrette pas je crois qu'avec du
recul ça va être ça va être très très
bien y croyez encore ouais vous n'êtes
pas encore complètement déçu passer sa
voiture là où c'est tout le monde est
cher mais non je suis je regrette rien
faut pas gratter non vous n'êtes pas
déçu par l'après match lors tous les
deux non non non on s'attend les outils
des choses on est on était très très
amoureux quand un bachelor ça a été un
truc de folie et on s'attendait pas on
s'attendait pas à rencontrer autant de
problèmes
voilà de retour dans l'arène et je crois
que c'est normal il ya eu des problèmes
olivier c'est vrai que j'ai peu de
propositions de l'épreuve bas peu de
propositions de boulot je vais du boulot
vrai nom j'en ai pas eu du tout savoir
alors qu'il ya d'autres gagnants
d'autres je me savais pas les gens
pensent que j'ai peut-être pas un
certain talent et que c'est un donc j'ai
pas eu une proposition mais ça c'est pas
grave
ouais comment ça va votre couple
aujourd'hui sérieusement ça va on a des
hauts et des bas comme dans c'est que je
m'en tiens compte qu'elle était
complètement fabriquée par la télévision
se peut fonctionner au delà de
l'émission s'est pressée je sais pas si
on peut dire qu'on était complètement
fabriquée on s'est rencontrés dans des
conditions particulières et
inconsciemment
tout ce qui se passait autour de nous à
jouer une manière différente
on va dire on n'a pas été totalement
fabriquées je viens nous les sentiments
qu'on a
l'un pour l'autre on peut pas aller
contre les joueurs peu importe ce qui se
passe dans n'importe quelle émission
j'ai un sentiment sané on sait pas d'où
ça vient et comment sont fabriqués en
août qui durent pas après l'été un
sentiment je viens rencontrer dans la
rue je sais pas bah rien du tout et je
convie les jeunes et femmes et les
filles qui ont des grosses amoureux mais
bon alexandra est ce qu'il est toujours
aussi galant dans la vraie vie pas
toujours non fatima voilà est-ce qu'il
est toujours super bien coiffés au
réveil est ce qui marque une pause
pendant la pub est ce qu'il boit des
bières
est ce qu'il boit des bières on regarde
en dessous c'est la télé quand j'en
achète way est ce qu'ils se battent les
couilles en regardant quand elle achète
alors qu'ils passent le plus de temps à
celle de ben ouais mon paquet plus
bordélique on sait que c'est alexandre
alors en jeu rien moi ça m'énerverais
voilà je vais vous dire vous êtes la
patience
olivia qui est le plus imaginatif all i
bat l alors je rien
qui est le plus jeune ou moi qui ai le
plus fidèle nous c'est à dire bien et
condé qui porte la culotte
je crois que non mais c'est en train de
changer et le serez certain de changer
la tête
[Musique]
alors fidèle à votre image olivier vous
ouvrez un site de rencontres amoureuses
sur internet
alors il ya des rencontres effectivement
et en plus de ça y est des soirées des
soirées de rencontres dont vous restez
dans cette idée serait de rencontrer
encore rappelle quelque chose
bah oui tu vas tu as peut-être aller sur
106 je trouve you will beall dit le net
c'est romantique presse à rome antique
de rencontrer des gens sur internet
cc c'est nouveau et ça vaut lui c'est un
outil efficace performant et et pourquoi
ne pas l'essayer quoi je veux dire c'est
un autre lieu de rencontre alors vous
êtes connu devant tout le monde draguer
devant tout le monde
vous ne serez pas étonné qu'on fasse
l'interview devant tout le monde
[Musique]
est ce que vous vous séparez devant tout
le monde
ouais ouais ça doit arriver oui dans le
sens où c'est notre nom va le faire et
puis si tu sais pas quoi est ce que est
ce que vous vous engueuler devant tout
le monde
tous les couples est-ce que devant tout
le monde vous pouvez juré que l'émission
bachelor n'étaient pas truqués
oui toujours une bonne jurés dit john
judd
est-ce que devant tout le monde peut
dire combien ça rapporte un truc pareil
à nous à nous pas grand chose quoi en
argent nom prénom choix on est payés
parfois pour des reportages photos mais
c'est souvent pages non est-ce que
devant tout le monde
vous pourriez vous dire je t'aime là
j'ai envie de le faire
oh
et si je vais vous laisser filer avec
votre petit lapin est votre livre
érotique orvacs voilà
il est bien s'en sont pas bons mais
n'étaient que j'avais vécu les mines et
qu'elle soit c'est la casserole
jalonneront ça oui
et maintenant
tiens qu'est jean christophe rufin
[Musique]
jean christophe est un bon soir dont
laurent baffie patrick sébastien jean
luc lemoine monsieur madame bachelor à
ne pas confondre avec monsieur madame le
millionnaire joey starr et d'atouts
voilà alors vous jean christophe rufin
vous êtes médecin l'un des fameux french
doctor de médecins sans frontières
et aujourd'hui vous avez rejoint action
contre la faim dont vous êtes le
président bénévole voilà leurs études
poussées vers la médecine par le
parcours de votre grand père lui même
médecin qui d'abord avait soigné des
combattants pendant la première guerre
mondiale et ensuite pendant la deuxième
guerre mondiale il avait caché des
résistants je vous habitiez à bourges et
c'était près de la ligne de démarcation
et ceux ci lui avaient valu d'être
déportée pendant deux ans à buchenwald
voilà donc ce qui vous a amené à la
médecine mais vous avez trouvé quel type
de médecine vous cherchiez en tunisie
pendant votre service militaire dans une
maternité à sousse voilà alors ceci
explique votre intérêt pour la fracture
nord sud
et puis aussi que vos premiers sujets
ceux de vos essais puis de vos romans
d'ailleurs et étaient des sujets je
dirais exotiques comme la bi 5 et eu le
goncourt du premier roman les causes
perdues qui a eu le prix interallié
rouge brésil prix goncourt 2001 qui
s'est vendu à 600 mille exemplaires et
qui a été traduit en 19 langues et
maintenant donc vous gagnez votre vie
évidemment avec les livres mais quand on
vous pose la question vous dites que
vous êtes médecin
j'ai toujours médecin jouer je suis
médecin et je dois dire que je suis très
fier de ce métier alors jean christophe
dont vous publié aujourd'hui globalia
chez gallimard
alors c'est toujours le même thème c'est
la rencontre entre des civilisations et
et ses conséquences
alors là c'est un c'est un essai plus
une épopée historique
1 une espèce de conte philosophique
romande aventure une utopie au sens un
peu voltairienne
du terme non oui si on veut enfin vous
savez j'avais un modèle dont les
créances bookers t 1984 d'orwell qui est
une espèce de dexter nerfs mise en scène
du totalitarisme
mais stalinien c'est quelque chose qui
finalement ne s'est pas produit et moi
je trouvais qu'il y avait dans la
démocratie aujourd'hui d'être est quand
même un peu inquiétant mais qu'il
fallait écrire le roman qu'on pouvait
essayer d'écrire le roman de ceux de ce
totalitarisme mou les choses sont pas
interdites mais où elle où elle
finalement la contrainte est quand même
créé par ça se passe dans la deuxième
moitié du xxième si la planète est
devenue le siège d'une démocratie
universelle qui s'appelle globalia
installés sous des bulles de verre
climatisé alors l'un des vices de
globalia ses libertés sécurité
prospérité alors c'est une espèce de
totalitarisme démocratique finalement
pire que le totalitarisme stalinien ou
nazi parce que là il n'y a pas
d'interdiction en fait qu'un exemple
c'est le tabac bon le tabassent et c'est
très bien aller contre le tabac
différent mais je crois qu'il ya aucune
société qui est allé aussi loin dans le
contrôle de l'individu et comme la
société démocratique ce sens légitime
elle veut fouiller jusque dans vos
parties s'il devient le tabac globalia
on peut fumer du tabac mais après il
faut faire de décontamination ans pour
un risque est effectif
les gens ils vont fumer dans des
endroits où il ya des grosses bottes
catalytique etc mais on n'est pas loin
de tous âges avec eux à l'heure actuelle
aux états-unis quand vous possédez un
cendrier dans votre bureau vous pouvez
avoir une amende parce que posséder un
cendrier ça veut dire que peut-être vous
pouvez avoir l'idée fumer c'est servir
même pas le fait d'avoir du talent c'est
le fait d'avoir l'idée de fumée alors
globalia c'est une espèce de démocratie
parfaite entre guillemets alors la
liberté d'expression est totale mais
mais peu de gens s'écartent des opinions
convenu ce qui est exactement
d'ailleurs le cas évidemment c'est us et
une critique terrible de la société
occidentale actuelle par exemple les
livres alors les livres sont pas
interdits mais il ya tellement de livres
qui sont publiés chaque jour qu'à la
sortie finalement les livres n'ont plus
d'importance donc cesser trop de livres
à tuer lima sur l'ellipse il voulait
dans les pays qui ont interdit les
bouquins les bouquins sont devenus très
précieux dans en union soviétique les
juristes les passer sous le manteau des
terres parce que c'était interdit savez
une valeur aujourd'hui vous allez dans
une ivresse êtes devant un immense choix
restera de bouquins et moi je me
souviens du goncourt des lycéens comme
ça on rencontre des lycéens il y avait
discuté ici à vous disais mais
maintenant on sait pas quoi lire on en
trouverait ya trop de trucs donc
finalement bas on préfère mettre un dvd
au moins là on sait à peu près certain
taylor et c'est ça je crois que le
totalitarisme démocratique c'est ça
c'est ce paradoxe de l'abondance qui
finit par tuer la vire nation par la
bombe dans un sens c'est ça alors c'est
évidemment les droits de l'homme avec
une conception comme très individualiste
des droits de l'homme par exemple
l'objectif c'est de vivre le plus
longtemps possible alors une espèce de
jeunesse éternelle qui est sans cesse
régénérée refabriquer par le maquillage
par la chirurgie esthétique
il ya plus de date il n'ya plus
d'histoire il ya plus de temps à dire
que tous les 60 ans on remet que comme
les heures et les minutes elle remet les
compteurs à zéro 1 s'éteindront
technologique il ne faut pas gadget
c'est plutôt l'aspiration de boris vian
dans l'écumé des jours très classe de
poésie un peu surréaliste tout mais bon
ya cette idée par exemple que dans les
droits de l'homme jeu parfait droit de
moi je suis un militant 4 g et si vous
voulez pousser à l'extrême ça devient
absurde de dire que si vous dites que
j'ai le droit d'être plus vieux possible
de rester jeune le plus longtemps
possible c'est à vous tombez sur cette
société de 100 ter ya plus de jeunes
plus d'enfants rien des vieux c'est moi
je fais souvent l'aller retour avec des
pays du tiers-monde 1 et c'est vrai que
c'est un des thèmes du bouquin c'est à
dire ceux ce passage
ce qui me frappe quand je reviens d'un
pays du sud c'est qu'il ya plus
d'enfants ici c'est l'absence des gosses
c'est le fait que espèce de de demande
qu'en effet c'est sécurité prospérité
c'est à dire le thème de davos la
semaine prochaine oriente davos sécurité
pour spécial dormir direz vous bon et
bien voilà
mais finalement il ya ça avec une grande
tristesse et une grande un grand
appauvrissement finalement alors bien
sûr il ya cette prospérité mon la paye
d'un prix très très lourd et que vous
avez dans des pays du sud
bien sûr il ya la violence bien sûr il
ya la guerre bien sûr il ya une forme de
drame mais il ya aussi une humanité plus
vivant il ya de la musique qui a delà
des langues différentes il ya des voix
là est une espèce de créativité la ccsa
ces deux mondes en face la face de
l'autre globalia c'est effectivement
mortalité 0 fécondité 0 les jeunes sont
détestés il y en a plus c'est exactement
ce que vous dites est en fait les
vieillards ont pris dans le monde
important savoir ce qui est très
intéressant dans notre bouquin c'est les
mots par jean grenet pas les vieillards
ont dit les personnes de grand avenir
on dit pas par exemple à la télé il ya
des programmes ça va intéresser olivier
alexandre à la télévision il ya des
programmes de lutte contre l'anonymat
c'est à dire que dans tout le monde peut
devenir star tout le monde tout le monde
peut gagner son jour de gloire
voilà bien tout le monde d'ailleurs
parce que cotent ya tellement de chaînes
de télévision que le programme que de
lutte contre la non humains et finit par
ennuyer tout le monde d'autre personne
ne veut plus venir parce qu'alors il est
l'aîné mais les filles qui s'appelle les
officiers de protection sociale ya des
centres de promotion du bonheur la
prison s'appelle centre dead à la
cohésion sociale est en fait cette
cohésion et là on est vraiment dans la
critique de notre monde actuel
cette cohésion et obtenu par la création
d' ennemi par le terrorisme alors ce
qu'il faut dire c'est qu'à globalia
c'est pas toute la planète un certain
nombre de deux zones sur la planète et
puis il ya ce que vous appelez les noms
zones qui sont lier qui l'a alors c'est
vraiment à ciel ouvert c'est c'est une
une partie de la planète qui est livrée
à des gens qu'on connaît pas des hordes
aller ce qui s'appelle les terroristes
globalia c'est c'est notre bulle ces
deux bulles finalement vit dans une
bulle
dans une bulle moi je les figures est
concrètement avec une bulle de verre
mais cette bulle elle n'est pas encore
en verre mais elle est déjà là s'il
fallait voir alors on la franchit assez
facilement vous vous êtes dans des
quartiers prospères vous êtes sous la
bulle vous franchissez vous allez dans
des banlieues ça ou ça casse tant qu un
petit peu vous êtes plus où la bulle
vous allez dans le tiers-monde n'est
plus sous la dent et effectivement ce
monde nous cette totalitarisme un peu
mou cette espèce de démocratie comme ça
très molle faut qu'elles se font qu'elle
tienne par l'extérieur pour tenir pas
l'extérieur
faux lui désigner un ennemi on voit très
bien en ce moment enfin ça tombe bien
j'ai pas écrit le bouquin pour ça et ça
tombe comme ça vous ouvrez votre télé et
vous voyez en ce moment des soldats en
armes faire des manoeuvres sur le golden
gate bridge
parce qu'on vous dit ça va sauter les
aéroports vont sauter etc il ya des
flics absolument partout et c'est pas
pareil que le risque le risque il existe
là c'est autre chose c'est pas le risque
c'est la mise en scène de la peur qui
fait partie de notre société
alors ces noms zone effectivement une
espèce de danse et non zone
effectivement il ya une espèce de
population divisée qui retournait à
l'état tribales ces sont les barbares de
l' empire en fait est là on rejoint un
essai à vous qui s'appelait l'empiré les
nouveaux barbares donc on est toujours
quand même des toujours fidèle à votre à
votre ligne
et puis quand on les bombarde quelques
temps après on leur balance ddd vivre
quoi la nourriture des médicaments ont
fait des largages humanitaire quoi oui
ben ça malheureusement n'est plus
habitué à ça c'est à dire que alors là
c'est ma casquette disons 2
d'humanitaire je m'occupe d'une ong
action contre la faim qui est très peu
présente dans 30 pays dans le monde plus
de conflits etc est de plus en plus on
essaie de nous mettre dans le sillage
des bombes un mandat sillage des armées
sur l'afghanistan l'irak a cédé emerica
y avait un sketch des guignols y larguer
des bombes et ils arguaient des bouffées
démo est là ou bien coup il se bourrait
il était un peu emmerdé c'est exactement
le bouquin bon voilà il ya globalia y
aller non zone et à l'intérieur de
globalia il ya un héros qui s'appelle
baïkal est une héroïne qui s'appelle
kate c'est une espèce de d'adam et eve
en fait d'un monde qui réconcilie ray
globalia et les noms zone alors lui il
est pas pour les terroristes mais ce
qu'on lui reproche en fait c'est que il
pense que les terroristes n'existe pas
et que c'est une invention de la
propagande
bah oui il est un peu plus sceptique
disons c'est à dire que c'est sûr il ya
des risques bien sûr il ya des gens qui
tentent en font péter une voiture piégée
quelque part mais cette espèce de
réduction complète de tout ce qui n'est
pas nous à la peur et au terrorisme s'il
voulait ça ils n'acceptent pas alors
cette salle il d'aventuré un roman de
valeur parce que généreront de ses
débuts après il ya toute une aventure
puisque ce baïkal va quitter globalia
avec kate pour passer dans les noms zone
et il va être lancé par rat parle parle
parle pop pouvoir comme un nouvel ennemi
les traités de jeunes fanatiques qui a
juré la destruction de la société
démocratique
donc il va être recherché enfin là il ya
tout un tas d'aventurés quand je suis
dans votre bouquin avec bien entendu
j'aurais contré par checa
franchement bravo c'est un très très bon
bouquin et je pense là en vendre autant
que le précédent ces panneaux
voilà jean christophe bagdad
c'est publié son gamer's
[Musique]
christophe merci les rails
allez
j'accueille maintenant tu mènes kate
à
[Musique]
atmen kelif bonsoir bonsoir moi j'ai ils
ont la même veste de judo c'est plutôt
karim le rmiste c'est pas greg le
millionnaire ça va ça va très très bien
merci de m'accueillir avec plaisir leur
est même ses trente trois ans vous êtes
né à albi parents originaires d'algérie
oui en 91 vous êtes venu au
conservatoire à paris oui pourquoi comme
ça vous êtes parti non mais je me suis
dit si je veux être comédien il faut
avoir des bonnes bases pour prouver à
mes amis que j'étais un comédien et il
fallait que je passe le conservatoire et
voilà ensuite vous avez été dans la
compagnie deschamps et makeïeff alias
les déchire les chiens et puis vous avez
fait une vingtaine de films du théâtre
et même du classique vous avez joué quoi
comme kia soul classique des marivaux
des molières dernièrement la pièce de
jean michel ribes au théâtre sans
animaux
ouais bah non un an et puis voilà de la
télé plein de trucs alors pour canal +
et fait des sketches avec lorànt deutsch
qui s'appelle à la recherche d'un emploi
tout afin une série de sketches où il y
avez-vous avec deux chipies un certain
nombre d'invités exceptionnels qu'est ce
que c'est ça je me lance des sms de
temps en temps
c'est comme ça que sa part voilà parce
que comme je me suis dit c'est faire une
promo compact temps en temps quand vous
avez des sympas avec moi il est balancé
des six prévus 10 du petit truc comme ça
dès qu'il se passait
donc voilà la recherche de l'emploi donc
atmen kelif lorànt deutsch on regarde à
quoi ça ressemble
[Musique]
pas la balle parfois tu serais pas de la
fanfare temps maintenant bras levés et
regarde droit devant
c'est génial ce surf la mienne très bien
je serai dans les stations
[Musique]
j'arrive pas les lâcher simulation fait
le taxi moi je vais faire le client
bonjour monsieur je vous dépose ou
bonjour situ j'aurais bien aimé aller à
la de triomphe c'est bien à paris le
trio capitaine blaise qui va payer les
corsaires falloir bosser ma petite
chatte donc c'est comment ça on n'a pas
de qualification c'est vrai il sait rien
faire les essais c'est un truc que vous
savez faire c'est la lessive la
recherche d'un emploi
vous prétendez
libéré c'est génial encore servait bien
alors au cinéma on va voir dans quoi au
mois de mai dans un film de bob swaim
qui avait fait la balance qui s'appelle
nos amis les flics qui est qu est un
polar d'action avec lorànt deutsch
encore une fois là bas oui lille un
petit rôle
il est venu faire un petit coucou de
copains il ya différentes al frédéric il
ya daniel auteuil dans le rôle du
méchant
et puis après au mois de septembre 1 une
comédie dramatique avec emmanuelle béart
et loire belle doit boire de marion
vernoux le tournage j'ai commencé dans
le tournage est fini là avant j'ai
arrêté de boire mais il était temps bien
en tous les cas elle est sympa
emmanuelle béart non elle était géniale
je voulais venir avec et la semaine
dernière j'adore aller c'est une fille
géniale dernière parce que on adore ici
elle a la sympathie d'une led
voilà
[Musique]
tuvalu d'une carte devant client élevé
génial j'ai la carte bleue maintenant
génial bon mais je la garde merci au
pinceau blind test
aux platines j'accueille dj mehdi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
hier alors vous connaissez le principe
je veux l'interprète bien entendu me
donnait pas les titres des chansons ça
sert à rien je veux l'interprète mehdi à
toi le voile
bon là lantieri plus serge
alors attention on n'a rien
m
oui
[Applaudissements]
ça
gaza un coin pour l'équipe de patrick
sébastien voilà et zéro point pour
l'équipe de joeystarr c'est joey starr
contre patrick achi c'est un match au
sommet c'est bien déjà pas l'irak en
français mais tu m'as on va y arriver
bientôt
attention donc je suis signale que c'est
agatha qui remplace méline la pauvre
méline est tombé à qu'elle s'est fait
mal au genou voilà bien méritée numéro 2
mais on voit olivier
m
kbc nationaux ou bravo
le bachelor marque un point ça fait un
point partout un point pour l'équipe de
sébastien
non l'équipe de juristes à un partout un
partout attention ça tu vas trouver de
jouer tout de suite
attention mais dit
en imposant de replay j'ai entendu dadou
et joey le dire en même temps génial
chantant
l'art est champion je vous demande de
vous arrêter
exactement attention mais dit
jean luc lemoine continue mairie
aujourd'hui
je sais
il a dit avant et bien avant il a dit m
avant tout le monde se fait quoi agatha
ça fait dur et quand je dis ou pas je
demande juste aux risques de faire
casser la gueule
non je connais pas en mai la quatrième
chanson te vois tu as déjà 5 points
je sois
le seul
un point dans cette merde c'en était une
attention mais dit numéro 5
je
[Musique]
quel bonheur
voilà donc ça fait 3 points pour
l'équipe de patrick sébastien deux
points dans l'équipe
[Applaudissements]
attention v10
c'est toi qu'est d'année eh ben le point
bas là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous avez un tournoi où l'agglo d'or
regarde quand vous le souffle et ici ça
va là si vous vous plaisez là bas si
c'est normal mais la vie est injuste
mais oui c'est comme ça attention tu y
es mehdi numéro 7
jean luc lemoine camp d'été
[Musique]
pas
m
on écoute première de la soirée même si
il ya une reprise qui était faite par
bono dit dont je ne savais pas j'ai
découvert ça logements plus et c'est pas
grave mais c'est pas grave on continue
mehdi
[Musique]
allo
achat sotra
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le trio
à
un petit geste pour patrick sébastien
quand même on n'a aucune chanson
française ne peut pas se battre là
dedans et puis en plus pas forcément est
chanceux bercero des chansons et des
chansons orale quoi qui est l'auteur de
ça
m
le manège
moi ya pas que ça la chanson française
je préfère celui que je préfère c'est
celui-là
oui ça
et oh
bernard dagen mehdi la suite du violent
voilà c'est fait
hier deux places oui
à
ça fait alors ah là là je suis un petit
peu désolé patrick l'équipe de joey
starr est à cinq points
[Applaudissements]
non et comment c'est toi qui n'existe
pas ça c'est qu'ils se cassent mana
casque est morte étouffée par un
sandwich non mais attends bon bah oui
c'est un mauvais président attention
mais vit un peu de vague est d'ailleurs
oui
mais d'autres mails en
[Musique]
oui
bravo mais dit c'est formidable on
continu numéro 11 attention
ouais
mais motus
[Applaudissements]
quand tu es
est immense
m
[Musique]
bravo parce que si on met l'ambiance je
vais te dire je vais te dire un truc
ce qui est étonnant c'est que ce sont
que ce soit les mammas où les papas ou
dylan c'est des trucs que tu étais pas
nés quand c'est sorti quoi si oui
j'écoute quand même un peu que c'est
bien mais c'est vachement bien
alors voilà donc maintenant pas éclipser
l'équipe de joey starr qui a gagné par
six points
[Applaudissements]
mais maintenant mes enfants il ya la
série des banques or il ya plus l'équipe
c'est chacun pour sa gueule on est bien
d'accord
attention vous connaissez plus personne
capitalisme maintenant c'est le
libéralisme gouvernement le
néolibéralisme l'ultralibéralisme chacun
pour sa gueule on y va le bon coup
d'abord mehdi
[Musique]
les strokes
bravo ce sont des collabos je suis du
terroir vendéen
c'est pas de vision du terroir un pas du
tout leurs seniors ça c'est pas le
terroir c'est non alors voilà donc ça
fait apprécier des sous bocks la
bestiole un coin pour personne m'a
beaucoup en hiver mais rien ici
le super banco mehdi
[Musique]
ouais
j'aurais jamais dû arrêter d'être dj
parce que quand je vois tu as commencé a
remué les gens la musique c'est
extraordinaire alors maintenant
évidemment le méga banco ça veut dire
que le gagnant du méga banques aux sera
le gagnant de toute la soirée
j'ai peur que ce soit dadou je sais pas
pourquoi oui il est trop fort et fort
mais toi tu es fort et mieux siens
attention donc la gère des tons fait
très très inquiet mais je pense que tu
vas trouver
attention le mega man comédie
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu as vu le clip de ça comme il est bien
à la le film prend les 50 personnages
tous habillés en jockey envers ébranle
est au branle être sinon c'est la fin
d'une où il peut leur mettre la semble
aime ça
tiens aussi à vous signaler le disque de
dj mehdi qui s'appelle the story of
espion
voilà dj benny blanco vous l'entendrez à
la fin de l'émission roulante
et à promouvoir dj mehdi merci beaucoup
c'est effectivement la barre l'homme
j'ai encore faim
là
donc hors jeu
et le dvd de l'autre côté du miroir sur
le 23 février
merci papy natasha st pier
[Musique]
le ressort de la fraise et
du lundi 22 février et les 24 septembre
jean louis dumas
31 janvier au bataclan
je vais
joey starr & dadou
le sort de là
sortie le 27 janvier et ont pendant les
dix neuvième avec un chabab et jean paul
rouve
voilà je
tu as se bat contre mike tyson je suis
devant ça avec ap il
jean-claude choix d'un style à
montélimar
durocher
il à branne m
par le roi mohamed 6 mai qui retourne au
maroc
les gens de saint géry olivier seo
son site inca
[Musique]
vous
avec son palais
[Musique]
m
jean-christophe
globalia chez gallimard acmé
monsieur c
à la recherche d'un emploi avec l'ong
merci m
dj mehdi
l'album certaines chaumières
voilà et puis
j'étais spa chez gallimard voilà j'ai
dit aux panthers sans frontières l'album
des bouches du rhône pour la liberté de
la presse au prix de 8 euros au profit
des journalistes emprisonnés dans le
monde et dieu sait saison et des avis
lamrabet la section lanta
ce faux jeu
moi j'ai les boules
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
[Musique]
m
des thèmes
tél